kennedy's peace speech at american
university and the growth and power of
the national security council which
advises the president panelists also
talk about president kennedy's
assassination in november of 1963
and explore some of the various theories
surrounding that event this discussion
was part of a conference hosted by the
future of freedom foundation it's just
over three hours
uh you know several years ago i was at a
libertarian social function and somebody
came up to me and said what do you
consider the biggest threat to our
freedom and our well-being our economic
well-being
and i suspect they thought i was going
to say oh the terrorists or the muslims
or the communists or the illegal aliens
or the drug dealers or something and i
didn't hesitate
i said the biggest threat is the
national security state
both economically in terms of the money
that they're spending the debt they're
incurring that's bankrupting the country
but also in terms of the destruction
of our liberty
and over the years i've mulled over the
thought of having a conference many of
you know that we've written a lot on the
the kennedy assassination which is part
of this overall structure of
analyzing the national security state
especially kennedy's war against the cia
and the pentagon joint chiefs of staff
and about three years ago i started
mulling over a conference like this and
i thought you know if i could bring
together the speakers that have had a
big impact on me and my intellectual
development it would be so exciting and
finally we decided we're going to do it
and so we put this thing together and lo
and behold the speakers that i invited
that you're going to be here today
everybody said yes
and i was just so pleasantly surprised
and excited because these every one of
these people that are speaking today
have been for me
heroes
their work has been heroic in terms of
of what we're going to be examining
today
and so it's it's exciting to be putting
this program together and i i want to
thank you for coming uh we we're
videotaping the proceedings the
videotapes are going to be free online
for people to access later on you
provide the audience for the speakers
you provide the energy for the speaker
so it's great to have you here i want to
especially thank those of you that that
have supported us with donations over
the years
we couldn't put on programs like this
without your donations we have a monthly
journal called future freedom and it
goes for 25 dollars you can subscribe at
our website at fff.org we have a daily
publication called fff daily
that is um we put a lot of time energy
and thought to you every morning to 6
a.m and that's for free so we invite you
to subscribe to that but obviously the
25 subscriptions do not fund programs
like this and our tours and so forth
it's those of you that help us out in a
bigger way that enable us to do that and
i want to especially thank the people
that funded this conference as you can
imagine the 99
registration fee doesn't come close to
covering all the costs of the conference
and there's a particular uh
some people that that funded they gave
us the funds that enabled us to do this
conference and they want to remain
anonymous and and they know who they are
and we know who they are and we just
want to say thank you
as far as the format goes
as far as the format goes those of you
who have attended our conferences know
our normal format is we we have an hour
lecture and with 45 minutes with the
lecture and then 15 minutes q a
this is different we have so many
speakers
we have 11 speakers we didn't want you
to go home and say god didn't get my
money's worth for my 99 you know so we
got
a jam-packed schedule and we changed it
around we've eliminated now some breaks
and if you need to take a break fine uh
we're not gonna the show goes on but you
can see it later what you missed on the
videotape
and uh there will be no q a and every
speaker has been advised that he's got
to stop exactly at that moment because
you know what happens when you start
getting laid you start pushing forward
and we've got to finish at 6 15.
so it's going to be we're going to be
running a tight ship when there are
breaks like lunch or
coffee break please be in your seats
about two or three minutes beforehand so
we can then continue going so without
any further ado let me introduce our
first speaker
jeffrey sachs
jeffrey sachs holds the title of
university professor the highest rank
professor sip at columbia university
he's a special advisor to former u.n
secretary
general ban ki-moon on the millennium
development goals
saks has authored three new york times
bestsellers the end of poverty
commonwealth and the price of
civilization
his most recent book is the age of
sustainable development
at the age of 28 he became a full
professor with tenure at harvard
jeff was named one of time magazine's
100 most influential people in the world
in 2004 and 2005.
in 2013 he authored a book on president
john f kennedy's remarkable peace speech
at american university entitled to move
the world jfk's quest for peace and that
book is absolutely fantastic i cannot
recommend it more highly please welcome
jeffrey sacks
[Applause]
jacob thank you so much and
thank you for bringing us together for
this wonderful conference i feel very
privileged to be here and very thankful
to
have a chance to be together with you
this morning
um
i'm not a historian in a room filled
with historians
so that's a risky start
i am
a lover of jfk's
quest for peace as i'm going to describe
in in a moment and i'm sure that uh some
of the historians here can fill in
uh
some or even many of the pieces that uh
i'm going to describe this morning
i fell in love with the president
kennedy's speech on peace on
that he gave
in june
1963
and i'll explain why in in my remarks
and
i took that speech as a an example of a
kind of leadership
that
showed
how to inspire people to
a better world
and i had a wonderful
occasion
after
reading it and learning a bit about the
history of it i wouldn't say all of the
aspects and i was certainly not an
expert on the period
but i
was asked by
the bbc several years ago to give what
they call the brief lectures which are
global lectures and i spoke about the
challenges of sustainable development in
our world
and i devoted one of the lectures to
uh kennedy's peace speech
and i had the pleasure to have
theodor sorensen standing right
sitting right in front of me
as as i gave that uh lecture at columbia
university that's a little
nerve-wracking by the way
it's nerve-wracking enough for me to
have so many historians in the room but
it was nerve-wracking to have
the co-author of that speech i think
it's fair to say
sitting directly in front of me
and i gave my interpretation of the
speech
and walked down to
greet ted sorensen whom i knew and
afterwards became close friends with
and he said jeff
you got it
that was a great relief
and it gave me
both the confidence and the inspiration
to learn more
and to try to put
kennedy's
ideas into their historical context
and in fact i asked ted who was a
neighbor
at the time in new york city
and an incredibly wonderful wonderful
person
of course one of the greatest wordsmiths
in
uh
american political history uh and a
lovely individual uh i asked him whether
it would be all right if i
tried to write a book about the speech
and
he went one better said that we could
work on it together
and soon after
that
he had a stroke and died and so i never
had the chance to work on the speech
directly with him and to ask him all the
questions that
i then could not get direct answers to
about context and
and purpose and
some of the choices of
ideas
in the speech
and indeed i put aside the project a
little bit out of the grief and feeling
that it wasn't
really possible until
it
became the 50th anniversary of the
speech in
1963 and i said if i'm ever going to
write about this this is the only time
and so i wrote a book
called to move the world
which is a quotation of president
kennedy in one of his speeches to the
u.n
and it's about his quest for peace
so i i think that this is a suitable
i hope useful
opening to frame what will be a
wonderful discussion of many many themes
around kennedy and around the national
security state and around its dangers
and
those are themes of this foundation that
i agree completely with i regard our
national security state as a
profound
danger to us
and a profound infringement of our
freedom and a reckless war maker
in this world and i think kennedy
took brave steps to try to overcome
those tendencies of the war machine
and that's really the story of his quest
for peace at least in part
so i'll bring us
back to those days
starting with his inaugural address
on
january 20 1961 and in fact to talk a
little bit about
these events in a chronological way
for me
in this
remarkable address and
when you
read
and listen to again kennedy speeches of
course this is probably the most iconic
of all of them but the
entire
body of speeches is such a wonderful
treasure for america
and uh for a couple of years i drove my
kids completely crazy because i made
them listen over and over again to this
speech and that speech and you got to
listen to this and oh you have to hear
this
because the more
you listen the more it's not only
great ideas in my view and important
ideas but also a kind of poetry
and a kind of deep inspiration
but one of the things that kennedy said
early on
in his inaugural address is
the world is very different now
for manholes in his mortal hands the
power to abolish all forms of human
poverty
and all forms of human life
i quote this almost daily uh because my
work at the u.n involves trying to
abolish all forms of human poverty and i
think kennedy
was right about this
but
it's also important
in my view to understand president
kennedy's
basic thinking a certain kind of sadness
and a certain kind of awareness
of our danger to ourselves and of this
poignancy of modern
times uh almost you could say an
existential
reality of modern times that we are so
technologically
advanced so proficient that we can
accomplish
marvelous positive
things in longevity in health in ending
poverty
but at the same time we have the
capacity to completely
destroy ourselves and wreck the world
and
it's especially poignant in my view
because
studying kennedy's thinking about this
from
his pt 109 days to his days
as a senator and
his writings and speeches during his
presidential campaign which was a many
year campaign
to become president in 1961.
he thought about this poignancy hard and
he came into office determined to make
the world a safer place
and yet it turned out
and this is a
human fate
within a year and a half
he had even helped
not by design but by accident to bring
the world to the brink of
annihilation and that was a shocking
truth for him
and it was a shocking fact for for the
world
but i take this statement to be both
true
true for us
true in kennedy's time
and very much a framing of his own
thinking
well his administration of course
started with a debacle
uh one of the worst in american
foreign policy history actually because
it led on to
more debacles and
more
near disaster
and that was of course the c.i.a
inspired and led beya pigs invasion
and
this was something that was a legacy of
the eisenhower
administration it was cia planned
like most of these operations that the
cia
concocts to our very day
it was a massive failure
i think the cia gets
if it were a private company it would
have gone bankrupt about 26 times
because it is a massive failure of an
institution when it comes to the
covert war side and
the definitive mistake that we made was
in 1947 when
intelligence was combined with the
private army and this was a profound
error that truman knew at the time but
in a way let happen
and it continues to haunt us to this day
kennedy
tried to have it both ways famously in
the bay of pigs and and that is
he allowed it to go forward but with
deep misgivings and so he said you will
do it but no air cover it's kind of a
typical ham-handed
inexperienced president
i
couldn't stop it
doomed to fail in a way
failed massively
and
it was
of course not only a failure as an
operation but it was a massive foreign
policy debacle
and one of the things that i found very
interesting in researching the book is
reading
the compendium of
correspondence between kennedy and
khrushchev
which began with a congratulatory note
from khrushchev on kennedy's election
in when he was a president-elect and
then continued as many of you know in a
private
back channel
discussion which is an interesting thing
in in terms of our current
discussions back channels
are not all bad it depends what they're
used for of course
but kennedy and khrushchev developed a
back channel which i think saved the
world in the end
because it gave them a way to
communicate with each other and to build
confidence which turned out to be
crucial
for the world
uh but
the day of the bay of pigs uh there was
a cable from khrushchev to kennedy
saying you may not be aware of this but
your government is involved in
international piracy
and kennedy responded on april 18th i
have previous i have previously stated
and i repeat now that the united states
intends no military intervention in cuba
while refraining from military
intervention the people of the united
states do not conceal their admiration
for cuban patriots who wish to see a
democratic system in an independent cuba
so kennedy lied blatantly vulgarly
to khrushchev and this was the second
time in a short period of time that an
american president had lied blatantly
and vulgarly
to the soviet leader because eisenhower
had done it with the downing of the u2
gary powers flight just months before
it's a bad habit by the way
our president should not lie this way
and they should not lie in such uh
blatant stupid transparent ways so this
was a deep kennedy blunder in my view
that compounded the blunder of the bay
of pigs
khrushchev wrote back in a long letter
that you could summarize as saying are
you kidding
don't ever write to me like that again
but he said you write that the united
states intends no military intervention
in cuba but numerous facts known to the
whole world and to the government of the
united states of course better than to
anyone else speak differently
and
khrushchev goes on to tell the truth
that this is a u.s
operation
and don't you ever claim it isn't
and this is a disgrace and it's against
international law and you have invaded
an allied country of ours and
khrushchev was right and he had been
right with gary powers and
it's uh interesting uh
in this regard uh
recently with the death of svig
brzezinski who whom i admired for many
many things
i
it recalled an interview that he gave
recently before his death
about
the american support cia support for the
mujahideen in afghanistan
and
of course this is the birth of al qaeda
it's another completely in my view
disastrous cia
led operation
and the list is endless
of the cia botched
foreign policy disasters
but
in in this case the soviets claimed that
they invaded afghanistan
uh
because the cia was mucking around to
overthrow the afghan regime
and we laughed and mocked at that and
look at the soviet paranoia and the
excuse and brzezinski said
but of course it's true
we did this well before the soviet
invasion we hoped that it would trigger
a soviet invasion it was a great success
it triggered a soviet invasion it gave
them their vietnam of course it gave
maybe a million deaths it's a
it gave us al-qaeda did many many
awful things but
this kind of lying
is
what the security state does for a
living
and it is
one of our big weaknesses that we're
surrounded by lies all the time
and presidents speak lies relentlessly
it just flows off the tongue but
basically it is the covert cia
operations that lead to them
over and over again
well
i think the bay of pigs triggered many
awful things but this was a very
difficult period of the cold war anyway
from
1958 to
1963
it
was probably the
most dangerous moments of the cold war
uh all centered in
in germany
that was the main well not all centered
germany and cuba became of course the
two
uh places where the cold war nearly
became the end of the world
war
and
many things were going on this is a deep
uh
question about
what was really
the uh
essence of this conflict uh between uh
the u.s and the soviet union especially
at this time and why was khrushchev
pushing so hard
in in berlin
and i personally think the best
interpretation
of this
of any history that i know is by mark
trachtenberg at university of california
in his remarkable remarkable
series of articles and books culminating
in a book called the constructed piece
and he explains that basically
the
cold war to a very significant extent
surrounded the failures to solve the
german question
uh from the point of view of
of the soviet union
and the german question was
what
how to secure
soviet security
in
the post-world war ii
era
uh because uh germany was considered a
continuing threat
it was to everybody
the western argument was
we will
make that threat
go away by
giving
the
the squeeze of friendship
in the european
community and in nato
and so germany will become part of
a u.s western-led alliance but that
wasn't a great answer from the point of
view of
the soviet union and especially one of
eisenhower's ideas because eisenhower
was a
very shrewd and very capable man and
also
a
very uh
fiscal conservative very tight
on fiscal policy he wanted
security at the lowest cost so
one of his continuing ideas was that
europe should defend itself with its own
nuclear weapons
and
eisenhower
thought that
a nuclear germany might be the right
answer the u.s wouldn't have to have
troops in europe uh
germany would be able to defend itself
and and
from the soviet point of view a nuclear
germany
was just not attractive
in
the immediate aftermath of the nazi era
when
the soviet union had lost more people
and had more destruction and it had more
tragedy and the idea that now
having quote won the war
to end up even more vulnerable
was a profound point of
distress
and so trachtenberg's view is that a lot
of the cold war was what are you doing
you're
you're preventing the legitimate
security needs of
the soviet people
i find this very plausible by the way
from everything that i
have read
and the u.s was
either not very caring about it
or
rather flippant about it kennedy came to
appreciate those concerns in
trachtenberg's
view and i'll come back to that story
but things were hot
in
the berlin front from 58 onward
including the building of the berlin
wall
which
started to go up in 61 because of the
flood of people out of uh out of the gdr
uh
the u.s basically thought that this was
a reasonable
way to avoid outright conflict to to go
along with this
but it also led to another one of these
moments where
things could have completely
gone disastrous when
ten tanks from each side faced off
against each other at checkpoint charlie
and it was a test of nerves and
kennedy was cool
and
khrushchev was cool in the end and
this was
finally
resolved after a an extraordinarily
tense few days but we were repeatedly
probing the limits of
uh
stumbling into
thermonuclear war
and then fast forward
of course
khrushchev decided that in view of the
invasion of cuba
the alliance that was forming with
castro and the soviet union
the u.s nuclear weapons in turkey
and not very well protected exposed
dangerous and close to the soviet uh
borders that he would teach
kennedy a lesson
of to tell them what it's like
and to do that by installing uh
offensive
uh
nuclear
tipped missiles in cuba
and when khrushchev explained to grimiko
that he was going to do this gramiko
said are you crazy
this is insane what are you doing you're
going to cause a
nuclear war
and khrushchev laughed
by the various accounts that i've read
said
this isn't war this has nothing to do
with war this is just to stick it in in
kennedy's face so they get a taste of
their own
their own medicine it's not about war
and everything i have read and know
about khrushchev tells me that this is
right uh but that it was a little bit of
quid pro quo and don't invade again uh
don't and of course the us was planning
on invading again or killing castro in
one way or another this was very high on
on the agenda
and so khrushchev decided to do this and
we all know the uh
the
story and so i won't
recount it in in any detail
except that
it is for us because of the recordings
of xcom and the history
of what happened
absolutely
one of the most important events of
modern history
to remind us every day
dumb we are
how vulnerable we are to ourselves
and don't trust your generals
ever
about peace
maybe about war
but not about peace
because what is true is that if kennedy
had listened to the vast majority of his
advisors
and uh he had lemay in the room who was
basically on the verge of insubordinate
the whole
time
rude abrasive uh almost flirting with
the overt insubordination
we would have
we would not be here let's put it that
way
we came so close
during this period to
accidental launches
pilots going off course
uh
ships that could have fired
under the orders of their captains
advice that
weapons that were already primed to fire
and were on order to fire if attacked
were not yet ready
so many miscalculations
and the basic
the basic point that kept us alive
with all of the various
details uh and the back channels uh and
uh and uh the
famous genius of listening only to one
of the communications from cas from
khrushchev and ignoring the second one
and uh and robert kennedy's back
channels
to
the soviet leadership
kennedy
saved the world
i think it's really true to say
by being
human
and
profoundly decent
profoundly
rational profoundly
careful
and ultimately profoundly moral in my
view
and with the
basic idea that he had
which went back to that
statement in the inaugural address and
to his
feeling of this tragic side of
human
history and endeavor that don't make a
misstep
and it's humans on the other side
and that's a really really important
idea it's humans on the other side
this is not a very prevalent idea
uh in uh
most
diplomacy in most diplomacy it's vermin
on the other side it's sub-human people
on the other side it's animals on the
other side it's irrational
people on the other side it's people who
don't deserve to live on the other side
it's people who just hate us on the
other side it's people who hate us for
what we are on the other side
i think this is
almost always wrong
and kennedy felt
that it was humans on the other side
and
really
i think had a kind of feeling that
khrushchev was probably surrounded by
the same kind of people that he was
surrounded by and that khrushchev was
his
best buddy in this crisis
and that if he could if he and
khrushchev could hold the line against
their own hot heads
maybe they would find a way out of this
peacefully
and
that's
what happened
we were extraordinarily lucky
so many things could have gone wrong
but the more you revisit it and again i
think it's true of all
of our modern history
don't listen to the cia
about almost anything
in terms of operations
in terms of intelligence you give the
cia credit they spotted the missiles
i'm all for intelligence by the way
trying to figure out what's going on but
it should be intelligent first of all
but this covert war part
is the
where they fail
again and again and again
well
uh
what i
learned from my own
uh
amateur history uh you know reading
thinking
researching
this period for writing the book is that
the missile crisis profoundly affected
kennedy
i think it is fair to say it touched him
to his soul
i think it's fair to say that from
the october missile crisis to
the end of kennedy's life
in november 1963 kennedy
rose to
the level of greatness
that he had a depth of
humanity purpose vision statesmanship
and political agility
that
reaches the greatest achievements of the
american presidency
so the first a
year and three quarters
not so great stumbling around
but from the cuban missile crisis to the
end of his life
in my opinion true greatness
at the highest caliber of leadership
but one thing that kennedy really felt
was we cannot go on like this
we came too close
we despite the fact that he came in
determined to avoid the abyss there he
stood
at the abyss
and he and khrushchev had had an
experience
never shared by any other people on the
planet
that the fate of all of humanity was in
their hands
and they had almost lost everything
and i think that he was profoundly
transformed by this that's my reading
and that he was determined to find a way
back from the brink
and that's what i call his quest for
peace
it was a campaign for peace
and a campaign is a
strategized sustained effort
and he made it and he succeeded
and it was brilliant
now one step along the way was this
meeting which in trachtenberg's
mind
was a key moment
trachtenberg's history i should say
it was a key moment of
spurring
kennedy
because basically
de gaulle
started playing around
and saying to the to adenauer
who rather longed for nuclear germany
if if the americans won't do it i'll do
it
uh
we'll do it together i
i'll give you the
technical backing for a german nuclear
and i will pull you
out of
the u.s led
nato alliance this will be a
franco-german
alliance and you'll get your nuclear
weapons
and this
spurred kennedy even more
we need to resolve the german question
and we need to move to some solution
and
again i'm relying heavily on
trachtenberg's interpretation which i
find to be very cogent
that kennedy took a firm decision enough
of this germany will not be nuclearized
and we're not going to allow de gaulle
to do this
and we are going to move forward with an
understanding with the soviet union
and by recognizing the soviet interest
in a non-nuclear germany
we will be able to make
uh steps
to retreat from the brink so it's not
only blunders or bay of pigs and then
placing
offensive weapons in cuba but it's also
getting to the deeper political
questions
that will get us back from the brink and
i think this is important too we often
see the cold war i mean in america we
see it as only the soviet cause which is
nonsense
or we see it as just blunders which is
also nonsense the cold war had real
political issues and the core of it
had a lot to do with soviet security
which is something we never want to
consider
and i think this is a big mistake just
like we didn't so much like nuclear
weapons
in cuba
the soviet union didn't like them in
greece and turkey
and by the way this russia didn't much
like the idea of ukraine becoming part
of nato
and we just regard that as well that's
their choice as if it was castro's just
his choice
what to do
and this is the failure to think
symmetrically and
to take the other point of view and to
understand it's what my colleague at
columbia university robert jervis calls
the security dilemma also you always
think you're right we're just defensive
we're just defensive we just draw the
line right on the russian border
and we don't say at all well how would
this be viewed from the other side
and kennedy really
was brilliant at thinking
about the other side that was his genius
actually that's what kept us alive in
the end so after this so-called eliza
treaty kennedy sped up and said we're
going to stop
the nuclearization of germany
i'm going to
get involved in german politics because
adenauer is not going to get
this way
and we're going to
speed up the negotiations for a nuclear
test ban treaty which had been going on
and off for years and years and had been
stymied over many issues including the
inspection issue for underground testing
another great figure of the time
pope john the 23rd
who was dying of cancer
in the spring of 1963 said
i
will use my last remaining
uh
ounce of life and and
power to
try to help
move towards peace and he wrote a
magnificent encyclical called parchment
terrace piece on earth
and it was uh
norman cousins who was editor of the
saturday review was kind of a three-way
uh
back channel
connector of the vatican the white house
and the kremlin in the spring of 1963
bringing a hand-signed russian
translated copy of parchment terrorists
to khrushchev who was eagerly awaiting
it
and
the uh encyclical to kennedy who was
inspired by it
and department terrace is a wonderful
document it says that statecraft is not
just about power it's about morality
and states should deal with each other
on a moral standard it's not a standard
we believe in it's not what uh
realism and international affairs
teaches
i think
pope john xxiii had the right point uh
and it is that added bit of
uh
humanity on the other side which can
help to bring about the peace
well kennedy went on a campaign for this
treaty and he gave a speech on june 10
1963 which was the greatest speech of an
american president in modern history in
my view
and
if you haven't listened to it recently i
maybe not once a week is needed but uh
it's absolutely beautiful it's online
it's uh you can watch the whole speech
you can read it
it's
so beautiful it's uh
wonderful but kennedy's main idea in
this speech was he was talking not to
the soviet union do this do this do this
and we'll sign a treaty none of that
he was talking to the american people
saying we need to change our mentality
so that we can find the path to peace
never before or after do i know of
another presidential speech like this
and if some historians do i'd love to
know
let me just read a few uh parts of it
quickly and i'll try to keep
on time i speak of peace because of the
new face of war total war makes no sense
in an age where great powers can
maintain large and relatively
invulnerable nuclear forces and refuse
to surrender without resort to those
forces it makes no sense in an age where
a single nuclear weapon contains almost
10 times the explosive force delivered
by all the allied air forces in the
second world war
today the expenditure of billions of
dollars every year on weapons acquired
for the purpose of making sure we never
need them is essential to the keeping of
peace but surely the acquisition of such
idle stockpiles which can only destroy
and never create is not the only much
less the most efficient means of
assuring peace i speak of peace
therefore as the necessary rational end
of rational men
wonderful
and he's basically saying we're trapped
in a prisoner's dilemmas how a game
theorist would put it now can we find a
way to the cooperative outcome
does it really make sense that the arms
race is the only way
and then he says some say it is useless
to speak of peace or war law or world
disarmament and that it will be useless
until the leaders of the soviet union
adopt a more enlightened attitude i hope
they do
i believe we can help them to do it but
i also believe that we must re-examine
our own attitudes as individuals and as
a nation for our attitude is as
essential as theirs
that's remarkable in my opinion
i just don't know of any other
presidents that talk this way it's the
opposite of pandering it's challenging
it's asking to revisit one's own
ideas
so let us persevere peace not need not
be impracticable and war need not be
inevitable
by defining our goal more clearly by
making it seem more manageable and less
remote we can help all people to see it
to draw hope from it and to move
irresistibly toward it that was
kennedy's style of leadership and the
practicability in this time was a treaty
a partial nuclear test ban treaty which
he thought would be the stepping stone
to nuclear
non-proliferation
and then kennedy goes on to praise the
soviet union at the height of the cold
war months after the cuban missile
crisis magnificent
magnificent
it would be like the president praising
the achievements of persian culture and
the iranian people
today
unimaginable yet he did it
no government or social system is so
evil that its people must be considered
as lacking in virtue a wonderful term a
greek
classic term that played very heavily in
kennedy's thinking
as americans we find communism
profoundly repugnant as a negation of
personal freedom and dignity but we can
still hail the russian people for their
many achievements in science and space
in economic and industrial growth in
culture in acts of courage wonderful
to praise your counterpart
to tell
your own citizens we must re-examine
our own ideas
khrushchev immediately calls april
harriman the u.s envoy
at the kremlin to the kremlin
and says that is the greatest speech by
an american president since fdr i want
to make peace with this man
and within six weeks the treaty is
signed
the speech is an inspiration
the speech is a bridge the speech says
we're both human
we have a common interest we can find a
way out of this mess
incredibly kennedy gives
another magnificent speech the next day
and i just want to frame this because
for kennedy the interplay of our
domestic decency and our international
capacity to make peace and solve
problems was inextricable we don't feel
that way anymore
but kennedy gave his greatest speech on
desegregation
the very next day after the peace speech
that's a lot of good writing for ted
sorensen by the way
and he said
famously we are confronted primarily
with the mortal issue it is as old as
the scriptures and it is and as clear as
the american constitution
the heart of the question is whether all
americans are to be afforded equal
rights and equal opportunities whether
we are going to treat our fellow
americans as we want to be treated
it's the same reciprocal vision of
decency morality the golden rule
the humanity and this is
kennedy in um
in a period of true greatness
he went to berlin
uh and uh in berlin uh not only did he
say ish benign berliner but he convinced
the
german people
we are with you we will provide security
and he told the men you will not have
nuclear weapons
and both sides were needed
germany needed security and kennedy
convinced them we will be with you to
give you security but you will not be a
nuclear power
and he thereby cleared
the way
for a mutual peaceful understanding
with the soviet union
and he basically with the
politicians that he met made it clear
was time for the old man
adenauer to go
and for erhard to become the chancellor
and erhard adenauer
ended the chancellorship just a few
months
afterward
kennedy then gave another magnificent
speech in the irish
dial the parliament
and to me the most important line of
that great speech is indeed across the
gulfs and barriers that now divide us we
must remember that there are no
permanent enemies hostility today is a
fact but it is not a ruling law the
supreme reality of our time is our
indivisibility of children of god and
our common vulnerability on this planet
and this is his mission for peace
kennedy then took the case to the
american people
everything in his mind was okay we can
sign a treaty but i will not be woodrow
wilson in
1919. this could go down to defeat
the hardliners the right wing the
security establishment could fight this
requires politics and here is kennedy as
a ward level political brawler and as
the greatest statesman because that's
what great politics is he had to win a
vote
it wasn't just writing a great speech
it wasn't being a statesman being a
diplomat he had to win the vote
in the senate
and so he went on a magnificent campaign
called in the political chips went on
speaking gave press conferences got key
thought leaders around the united states
engaged
and
one senate ratification overwhelmingly
80 to 14
and this was the signing on october 7
1963
one of the great triumphs of political
vision
and political courage
then kennedy
spoke uh at uh
his last speech of course to the united
nations
another one you should listen to and
savor it's beautiful beyond belief
all the wonderful things we can do
using science for cooperation
working together fighting poverty
fighting hunger
kennedy is soaring at this moment
kennedy is reaching a level of
leadership
absolutely unparalleled
for
the this time
it's dazzling
and i love
the conclusion of the speech
he says two years ago i told this body
that the united states had proposed and
was willing to sign a limited test ban
treaty
today that treaty has been signed
it will not put an end to war
it will not remove basic conflicts it
will not secure freedom for all this is
kennedy-esque
he doesn't oversell
but it can be a lever
and as archimedes in explaining the
principles of the lever was said to have
declared to his friends
give me a place where i can stand
and i shall move the world
my fellow inhabitants of this planet
speaking to all the world leaders in
front of him
let us take our stand here
in this assembly of nations and let us
see if we
in our time
can move the world to a just and lasting
peace
it's amazing that in the midst of this
one more disaster
kennedy is kind of dragged
along
again the security state we got to take
out dm
a bloody coup many of you know kennedy
is aghast when he hears the news that dm
was not just overthrown but was murdered
and he runs out blanched from the oval
office he's so profoundly shaken
by it and feels tricked again
by
the security
state
let me
go two minutes over
uh just to conclude
a couple of lessons for some lessons for
peacemaking
define our goals clearly
we are trapped in what is called the
security dilemma
uh thinking everything we do is fine
everything the others do is uh is an
aggression
uh this is a we now know from
neuroscience that this is a kind of
confirmation bias or self bias that is
profoundly dangerous
peace needs to be constructed
it doesn't just happen
it has to be constructed around a common
political
idea
you need moral imagination moral
imagination means the belief that you're
dealing with human beings on the other
side
you need politics
this isn't just highfalutin thought you
need to win votes
and
i won't go into it at length i think all
these lessons are completely relevant
for us today
and i want to conclude with what i
believe are the most beautiful words of
any president
in modern history
from the peace speech
so let us not be blind to our
differences but let us also direct
attention to our common interests and
the means by which those differences can
be resolved
and if we cannot and now our differences
at least we can help make the world safe
for diversity for in the final analysis
our most basic common link is that we
all inhabit this small planet we all
breed the same error we all cherish our
children's futures and we are all mortal
thank you very much
bart
[Music]
michael j glennon is professor of
international law at the fletcher school
of school in democracy of law and
democracy at tufts university
he has been legal counsel to the senate
foreign relations committee
a fellow at the woodrow wilson
international center for scholars in
washington d.c
and thomas hawkins johnson visiting
scholar at the united states military
academy at west point
professor glennon has served as a
consultant to various congressional
committees the u.s state department and
the international atomic energy agency
he is a member of the american law
institute and the council for foreign
relations
professor glennon is the author of
numerous articles on constitutional and
international law as well as several
books
his op-ed pieces have appeared in the
new york times washington post los
angeles times international herald
tribune financial times and
frankfurt
al-jamin zaytong
the paperback edition of his latest book
national security and double government
was published this year by oxford
university press he's the author of the
article security breach in the current
issue of harper's magazine
i can tell you that this book national
security and double government is one of
the most profound and insightful books
you will ever read
it's with real pleasure please welcome
professor michael glennon
[Applause]
jacob thank you very much for that kind
introduction thanks for inviting me to
be here and for organizing this
wonderful conference
uh it's really a privilege to be a part
of it
i think it was worth coming from boston
just to hear professor sack's
magnificent speech thank you very much
for that
a couple of years ago i did
write this book that
i hope might shed
at least a little light on the
assassination of president kennedy
it's called national security and double
government as as jacob mentioned
it tries to explain a phenomenon that
professor sax just
alluded to the dominance of the national
security
bureaucracy in american policy making
the book drew largely on
my own experience
as legal counsel the senate foreign
relations committee in the 1970s
where i worked with senators frank
church
jacob javits george mcgovern
and their colleagues
in that capacity i did inevitably
learn a bit or at least hear a bit
about
the kennedy assassination
never discussed this publicly
but i think that
today is probably the right time to do
that
i must
tell you at the outset that i however
remain a
thoroughgoing skeptic
as i will suggest
when it comes to the making of national
security policy
i doubt that our government is what it
appears to be
i also doubt
that any firm conclusion
can be drawn from anything that i know
or anything that i have heard
concerning who was behind the
assassination of president kennedy
my skepticism is overcome however
by the record of the warrant commission
i have no doubt
that the warren commission
led the way in eroding public respect
for american institutions
and i have no doubt that the commission
was undermined in its investigation
by the same distrust of democracy
that has pushed the united states
led the way in eroding public respect
for american institute let me begin
therefore by
quickly outlining the notion of double
government theory was developed in
1867 by walter badgett one of the
founders of the economist magazine
his theory has since been regarded in
britain
as the most
respected and indeed probably the
standard explanation of how the british
government operates
in a nutshell badget's theory was this
power in britain
was initially exercised by
the monarch and the house of lords
badgett called these writtens dignified
institutions dignified in the sense that
they embody
memories of greatness they invoke the
grandeur of ages past with
magnificent pomp and ceremony
yet badgett wrote that it's in fact a
second set of
institutions
that do the real
day-to-day work of governing
these are britain's efficient
institutions the house of commons the
cabinet and the prime minister
they operate backstage
and over the years have moved britain
quietly
in the direction of a concealed republic
quietly and concealed
badgett said because a
a crisis of confidence would have
occurred
if the people had been aware of the
massive transfer
of power that had taken place
badget calls this dual structure double
government
i suggested in my book that in the years
following world war ii
the united states in the realm of
national security
has also slipped
unintentionally
into a system of double government
this explains in large part why national
security policy has changed so little
from one administration to the next most
notably from the
recent bush administration to the obama
administration
the american people have believed that
america's so-called dignified
institutions congress the president and
the courts
manage the nation's national security
but in reality
security policy has been formulated
largely by a concealed network
of several hundred
officials
who
had the military intelligence
and law enforcement agencies of the
united states government
these are the united states efficient
institutions
unlike
britain's experience however
america's double government
has moved steadily in the opposite
direction
away from
democratic accountability
and toward autocracy
this drift toward autocracy
has not in my view been the result of
any enormous nefarious conspiracy
quite the contrary the managers of the
security bureaucracy are for the most
part smart dedicated loyal patriotic
americans they simply respond often
entirely rationally to incentives
that are buried deeply within the
structure of the american political
system
they are specialists who are possessed
of
considerable experience
and expertise in the realm of national
security so naturally
they resist what they see as
kibitzing
by generalists in congress in the courts
or even on the president's own staff
conversely
judges and elected officials don't want
to take the blame
for potential
national security calamities
therefore
they have a powerful incentive
themselves to defer to the judgment of
the experts
over the years the net effect
of all this has been that the security
powers of congress the courts and even
the presidency
have trickled away
while the power of the bureaucracy
has steadily increased
obviously the dynamic is more
complicated than that but that's
basically how double government works
now
walter badgett believed that the
stability
of this dualist structure was made
possible indeed he believed that the
stability depended upon the dignified
and efficient institutions
presenting a united front to the public
and avoiding open disagreement
harmony between the two
at least in the eyes of the public
is essential badget believed to maintain
governmental legitimacy
an open split
would make the system dangerously
unstable
and badgett believed that the whole
structure under those circumstances
would like a spinning top
in his words
fall to earth
so until recently
both sets of institutions
responded to this incentive structure by
instinctively trying to present a public
show of unity
all this of course raises some
unsettling questions about america's
current situation
some of which i try to address in
harper's article in the current issue
an unprecedented open rift
has developed
between the intelligence community
and president trump
the question is what would it mean for
the system to fall to earth
can we should we
rely upon the military intelligence and
law enforcement bureaucracies
to block presidential policies that some
of us might consider misguided but which
are nonetheless democratically adopted
and which are at least arguably entirely
legal
now i won't address those questions here
you can probably guess my answer
except to suggest
that this is not the first time that
america's security bureaucracy has been
urged to step in
to play the role of platonic guardians
to save the people from themselves
i'm referring of course to the warren
commission
the security bureaucracy tried to steer
the commission toward what the cia later
referred to as
quote the best truth
i want to focus here today on one
specific way the cia's leaders tried to
do that
namely
by not disclosing to the commission that
the cia had been engaged in efforts to
assassinate fidel castro
three years ago the cia acknowledged in
a remarkably candid report
that the decision of quote agency
leaders in 1964
not to disclose information about the
cia's anti-castro schemes
might have done more to undermine the
credibility of the commission than
anything else that happened
while it was conducting its
investigation unquote
that's quite an
admission
but if anything i think it's rather an
understatement the warren commission
represented the very pinnacle of the
american establishment look at its
members
chief justice of the united states
former governor of california earl
warren
chairman of the senate armed services
committee richard russell after whom the
new senate office building is named
the house democratic whip hale boggs the
chairman of the house republican
conference gerald ford who'd become
president 10 years later
head of the chase manhattan bank ford
foundation at council on foreign
relations john mccloy
the brother of eisenhower's secretary of
state and former head of the cia alan
dulles
if the american people could not trust
these men
who could they trust
and the people did trust them
a week after kennedy's assassination
only 29 percent of people surveyed
believed that oswald acted alone
after the war commission released its
report ten years ten months later 87
percent of the american people believe
that oswald acted alone
in the coming years of course
in in dribs and drabs the truth
came out as it so often does
and the public learned what the
commission
had not learned
it learned that the cia under alan
dulles
had plotted to assassinate fidel castro
in november of last year abc news
reported that only 32 percent of the
american people now believe that oswald
acted alone
68 percent of americans believe that
there was an official cover-up
to hide the truth about the
assassination from the public
so the reality is that the cia's
non-disclosure of its efforts to kill
castro
undermined far more
than the credibility of merely the
warring commission the agency's actions
undermine the credibility of the
american government
before the commission's report in
november of 1964 public trust in
american government was at an all-time
high listen to this 77 percent of the
american people trusted the government
just about always or most of the time
in june of 2013
79 of americans said they never trusted
the government
or did so only some of the time
obviously there have been many events
that have occurred over the last 50
years
uh
that have also eroded trust for the
government vietnam watergate iran contra
weapons of mass destruction in iraq you
know the list
but the warren commission's report
was the real deal breaker it was the
first and really the worst evidence
that is the great senator j william
fulbright later bluntly put it the
government
lies
it was the worst
because
president kennedy
was like family
to millions of americans
when i was in sixth grade i passed out
jfk all the way buttons at the back of
the nixon rally
i was the pro kennedy debater in our
civics class presidential debate i used
to come home from grade school in the
afternoon and watch his press
conferences
our family got teary-eyed laughing at
vaughn meters impersonation of kennedy
in the first family
many of my classmates
felt and reacted as i did we loved john
kennedy he was our president we had
never
loved
an elected be official before
at that point in our lives i i dare say
i think
most of us had never known anybody who
had died
kennedy's death hit us very hard it hit
us very hard
and then later we learned that the
government had
covered up important
facts about why he died the same
government that john kennedy had
inspired us to admire and trust
the warren commission had issued a
report that could not be trusted which
was the most shocking
and saddest realization of all the
american government could not be trusted
in the american government did not trust
the american people
now
think for a moment what the warren
commission might have asked if it had
been aware
of the cia's attempts to assassinate
fidel castro all the questions that have
since become fodder for conspiracy
theories could have been explored in a
thorough
high level professional investigation
while the evidence was still fresh
did castro know about the cia's plots to
kill him did he retaliate against
kennedy
was oswald working for the cubans
did oswald have accomplices in cuba or
elsewhere
were disgruntled
anti-castro cuban exiles involved
the cia is also also enlisted of course
the help of the mafia whose side was the
mafia really on
all those questions and many more
were relevant and material to the issue
whether oswald acted alone
none of those questions could have been
investigated adequately without knowing
that the cia engaged the mafia and
anti-castro cubans to kill fidel castro
so the obvious question for me at this
point is how the cia's omissions relate
to this idea of double government
think about this in considering three
specific issues first who knew
about the castro assassination plots
second when did they know it and third
why did they not inform the warren
commission
first who knew
richard helms testified before the house
assassinations committee in 1978 that
all kinds of people knew about these
operations high up in government
unquote helms was of course right so
let's begin with the cia
richard helms knew
helms was deputy director of plans
during the commission's investigation
he had earlier
either approved or participated directly
in several efforts to kill castro during
operation mongoose which attorney
general robert kennedy apparently
managed
helms said nothing about that to the
warren commission
dulles knew
the church committee was never able to
reach a firm conclusion
but a cia document that was declassified
in june of 2007 stated unequivocally
that in 1960 dulles quote was briefed
and gave his approval unquote to a plot
to assassinate castro
john mccon dulles's successor as dci
testified in 1978
that he assumed that dulles who was dci
when the plots
originated would have told the warrant
commission about the plots
he was after all a member of the
commission but he did not
john mcconne knew
mccone was dci when the warren
commission conducted its investigation
mccone claimed in that 1978 testimony
that he did not know about the plots
he said that knowledgeable cia employees
quote withheld that information from me
unquote
that statement the cia
euphemistically acknowledged in 2014
quote
was neither frank nor accurate
by the time mccone testified to the
commission in 1906 may of 1964 the cia
concluded mcqueen quote had known about
the mafia plots to kill castro for nine
months but he chose not to mention them
unquote
outside the cia j edgar hoover knew as
early as 1961
hoover said nothing to the commission
saddest of all
robert kennedy knew
kennedy was aware of the mafia's
involvement in cia efforts to kill
castro
since at least may of 1961
he was
then told in a memorandum from j edgar
hoover
kennedy was told again a year later by
cia briefers
bobby kennedy said nothing to the
commission
none of these individuals brought the
castro assassination bloc plots to the
commission's attention equally
significant
none of them brought the plots to the
attention of president lyndon johnson
at the time that johnson appointed the
members of the commission
which was a week after kennedy's
assassination
there is no convincing evidence that i
have seen
that johnson himself
knew about the cia's efforts to
assassinate castro before johnson made
those appointments
now let me stop here for just a moment
before addressing the why question to
add what may be an obvious caveat
i suggested that there's no convincing
evidence that johnson knew
it's easy to establish knowledge if
someone has been told something he knows
we look to evidence
it's next to impossible however to
establish ignorance
it's next to impossible because we
simply don't have and cannot get
evidence that a person was never told
something
this is particularly true when we're
talking about things that are not
reduced to writing like assassination
plots we know that alan dulles was
briefed and gave his approval because
there's documentary evidence in the
cia's files that establishes that he did
that but obviously there's no
documentary evidence that lyndon johnson
did not know
about the cia's plot
when he is appointed the commission's
membership
whispered conversations generally are
not documented
in its 2014 report on the kennedy
assassination the cia therefore rightly
pointed out
that it is not known if dulles told any
commissioners in private
about the cia's plots to kill castro
unquote
of course that is true it is also true
that we don't know whether bobby kennedy
told his friend earl warren in private
or what other private conversations
might have occurred all we do know is
what these individuals
told the warren commission on the record
about the plots and we know that they
said nothing
i once asked my friend the late john
hart ely
why the commission didn't investigate
the implications of the plots to kill
castro john was a lawyer on the
commission staff he was a law clerk to
chief justice earl warren he went on to
become a very prominent
constitutional law scholar and dean of
the stanford law school
i thought john's
answer to my question i must say was a
bit defensive he said
they didn't tell us
well of course john ely was right
so in the end it would not exonerate the
agency if some day it comes out that one
or more commissioners was privately told
about the castro assassination plots the
plot's implications were not explored
because the commission qua commission
was not told
nor is there any evidence that lyndon
johnson was told when he appointed
to the commission the mastermind of the
cover-up
alan dulles
in fact
the cia with dulles's connivance
probably crossed the line
from non-feasens
to malfeasance
the cia put it this way in a 2014 report
quote
under mccone's and helms's direction
the cia support for the warren
commission was
passive
reactive
and selective
cia produced information only in
response to commission requests
and did not volunteer material
even if potentially relevant for example
about agency plots to assassinate castro
unquote
helms told the house assassinations
committee in 1978 that if he wasn't
asked for it he didn't give it
dulles
by some accounts dominated the
proceedings of the warrant commission
he was fired by kennedy of course after
the bay of pigs debacle he was the only
member of the commission therefore who
did not have a full-time day job so he
had plenty of time to arrange
things
dulles forewarned agency officers about
the questions that he and his fellow
commissioners were likely to ask
there may have been no explicit
understanding between macon and dulles
that helped dulles
steer the commission away from
controversial agency
operations as the cia found in 2014 but
mccone the agency said this is a quote
from the agency's own report listen to
this
mccone the agency said quote may be
regarded as a co-conspirator
in the jfk assassination cover-up
unquote
the conspiracy to keep the conspiracy to
kill castro secret after november twenty
second
mccone the agency concluded could rest
assured that dulles would keep dutiful
watch over agency equities
and work to keep the commission from
pursuing provocative lines of
investigation such as the lethal
anti-castro covert actions
unquote
so the question is why
why did none of these individuals tell
the warrant commission
about the efforts to assassinate castro
the most generous explanation
is that they saw their
inaction
as averting potential war
if it turned out that castro was behind
kennedy's assassination
as helms put it
we could have had a very nasty situation
what would be the retaliation a startled
america could do some extreme things
unquote
lyndon johnson may not have known about
the cia's
plots to assassinate castro yet he
appeared to share the cia's impulse
to avoid the risks of war
that a full-scale
investigation could have entailed
johnson said quote
we've got to take this out of the arena
where they're testifying that khrushchev
or castro did this and chuck us into a
war that can kill 40 million americans
in an hour unquote
johnson used this fear
to browbeat
several men into accepting his
appointment to the warren commission
cia leaders soon concluded if they
hadn't already
that the route to the best truth
as the agency called it was to push the
story that oswald acted alone
in fact
that narrative may have been established
as early as three days
after the assassination
on november 25th 1963 the deputy
attorney general nicholas katzenbach
sent a famous memo
to president johnson's press secretary
bill moyers
katzenbach recommended that the
president appoint a commission
to investigate kennedy's death
and katzenbach laid out in that memo to
johnson what he thought should be the
commission's clear purpose
quote
the public must be satisfied that oswald
was the assassin
that he did not have confederates who
are still at large
unquote
the objective in other words
should not really be to investigate
the objective should be to calm the
public's fears and suspicions
and to avoid broader inquiries that
could lead to
personal embarrassment
national disgrace
and possibly even armed conflict
in february of 1964
earl warren himself seemed to
acknowledge as much
warren told reporters
right in the middle of the
commission's investigation that the
truth about the assassination might not
be known quote
in your lifetime unquote
of course people act for mixed motives
and it's not
it's easy to rationalize
darker intentions there there are in
fact less charitable reasons that may
explain
the actions of the cias and the fbi's
leaders
public disclosure of the plots
could have ruined their careers and
their reputations
disclosure could conceivably
have exposed them to criminal liability
it could have revealed omissions
negligence
and ham handedness in their conduct of
the investigation
particularly on the part of the fbi
it could therefore have generated calls
for
more rigorous congressional oversight
of agencies that at the time
were largely self-policing
and still are i might add
it could even have triggered efforts to
abolish the cia
or to get it out of
covert operations and limit its role to
intelligence gathering
harry truman proposed
just that in a stunning washington post
op-ed piece that was published only a
month
after kennedy's assassination
none of this explains robert kennedy's
silence
why didn't
robert kennedy inform the warrant
commission himself
following the bay of pig's fiasco after
all his brother had famously said that
he wished he could break the cia into a
thousand pieces and
scatter it to the winds
presumably
bobby kennedy shared that same impulse
at least for a while
but he himself was deeply involved in
the plots to assassinate fidel castro
and his animosity toward the agency
may
later have diminished
helms testified that the agency was
under considerable pressure from the
kennedy administration to get rid of
fidel castro
robert kennedy could have believed that
his brother standing in history
and his own reputation
would have been tarnished
if the castro assassination plots
ever became public
it's possible in fact
that robert kennedy blamed himself
for his brother's murder
when i worked for the senate foreign
relations committee
i had a conversation with senator george
mcgovern
that has always stuck in my mind
mcgovern was a friend of robert and
jacqueline kennedy
1978
mcgovern subcommittee on international
operations
was engaged in an inquiry
into the
activities of foreign intelligence
agencies within the united states
including dina
savak
and the other intelligence services of
some of america's
upstanding allies
my colleagues and i had recently
questioned cia officers
in langley
about the agency's
liaison relationship with these foreign
services
one day after work
i stopped by mcgovern's office
to brief him
on what we had learned
this was in 1978
no one else was present
mcgovern
mixed the two of us tanqueray martinis
the topic turned to
assassinations
and then the assassination of president
kennedy
i mentioned that
castro had warned only two months
beforehand
that
american leaders would not be safe
if they were aiding in terrorist plots
to kill cuban leaders
i was standing at the time staring out
the window in mcgovern mcgovern said
that after the assassination bobby
kennedy would come to his office and
just stare out the window like that for
the longest time
saying nothing
i said kennedy
might have been
inordinately depressed because
he felt responsible for his brother's
assassination
because castro found out about the plots
to kill him
and
retaliated
by ordering the assassination of
president kennedy
mcgovern said yes that is what bobby
believed
i had the temerity to ask mcgovern how
he knew that
mcgovern replied
jackie told me
let me be very clear about this
i myself
have no way of knowing whether castro
was in any way involved
or
what robert kennedy or jacqueline
kennedy
ultimately came to believe
or whether their beliefs
whatever they were in the end
were based upon
hard evidence
or sheer speculation
george mcgovern did not say that he
believed that castro was involved
however mcgovern never told me what he
believed and i did not ask
i knew ted sorensen i told sorensen
about this conversation with mcgovern
and i asked him who he believed was
behind kennedy's assassination
sorensen said he didn't know
and hadn't tried to find out
because nothing could bring john kennedy
back
because it was
too painful for him
to revisit the matter
when i was in cuba in the 1980s during
the long
multi-cigar afternoon with ricardo
allercone
i asked
him about this ricardo would
allercone had been castro's ambassador
to the u.n and was very close to fidel
castro
as i expected he would allercon denied
it he said that they the cubans would
have been
crazy to do such a thing
because the retaliation would have been
devastating if the americans found out
friends of mine who were on the church
committee staff tell me it's highly
likely that the mafia was behind
kennedy's assassination
i worked closely with frank church on
the foreign relations committee but i
never asked church
what he believed had happened
and i never heard church
express his own opinion
so in some i don't know
i have no fixed opinion
as to who was involved in president
kennedy's assassination or why he was
killed
the circumstantial evidence that i am
aware of is incomplete
and contradictory
more than one person
had a motive to kill kennedy
the capacity to do so
and the opportunity to do so
the cia cover-up discredited the warren
commission's investigation
but that obviously does not mean that
anyone in the cia was involved
nor does it mean that lee harvey oswald
did not act alone
i therefore conclude
by returning to the question that i
began with what does the cover-up of the
castro assassination plots have to do
with double government
the answer unfortunately is
a lot
and it still does
because the monumental lesson that that
cover-up teaches us still has not been
learned
double government subsists on insider
arrogance
the ultimate insiders the managers of
this nation's national security
bureaucracy
have acquired the broad power that they
now exercise
in the belief that they know better than
the american people what is best for
this nation's security
they have managed to convince congress
and the courts and even the president's
staff that they should be deferred to
because their expertise
will lead to wiser decisions than those
based on the judgment of the american
people and their elected representatives
dean atchison's attitude
perfectly embodied that belief atchison
said quote
if you truly had a democracy
and did what the people wanted
you'd go wrong every time
unquote
that was the belief of the cia leaders
who covered up
their plots
to assassinate fidel castro
the people can't handle the truth so we
have to give them the best truth
the truth
that omitted the agency's efforts to
kill castro
it was that distrust of government that
distrust in democracy
that distrust in the people
that more than anything else
led to the cover-up
the possibility did not seem to occur to
the agency that perhaps the people can
be trusted to know what's in their best
interest
that perhaps government distrust of the
people
causes the people to distrust the
government
that perhaps democracy would be
strengthened
not weakened
if government trusted the people
justice brandeis wrote
government is the potent the omnipresent
teacher
for good or ill
it teaches the whole people
by its example
seems to me that
if the government of this country ever
wants to be trusted again
it can start by setting an example
thank you
[Applause]
things
bart
bart
are we good to go here
we go
i'm sorry
okay
our next speaker stephen kinser is a
former new york times reporter and
is currently a world affairs columnist
for the boston globe
having taught at both northwestern
university and boston university he is
also currently a senior fellow in
international and public affairs at the
watson institute for international and
public affairs at brown university
a longtime critic of america's
interventionist foreign policy kinder's
books include bitter fruit the story of
the american coup in guatemala
all the shah's men and american coup in
the roots of middle east terror
overthrow america's century of regime
change from hawaii to iraq
the brothers john foster dulles allen
dulles and their secret world war and
most recently the true flag theodore
roosevelt mark twain and the birth of
american empire
all of which i have read in all of which
i cannot recommend too highly there are
absolutely fantastic books on america's
history of foreign interventionism
the title of stephen's talk is regime
change roots of the imperial temptation
please welcome stephen kinser
[Applause]
thank you it's wonderful to be here and
especially uh to be following two
such eminent scholars
you've now been given by the last two
speakers a picture of where we were
around the period of the early 1960s and
the kennedy assassination
so i've been asked to give something
like a prequel to those speeches
uh
how did we get here
i've been told by my publishers that
journalist memoirs never sell the only
people that ever buy them are other
journalists
uh therefore uh despite my efforts i've
been told by several publishers you're
you're never gonna sell a memoir forget
it so i've dropped out the idea of ever
writing a memoir but i do have a title
my other books usually work the other
way i get the book done and then come up
with a title now i have a title for
which there never will be a book
but it does encapsulate my approach to
uh trying to understand america and the
world it's a line from one of those old
movies that i love to watch um
called arsenic and old lace
remember that movie with cary grant so
for those of you that forgot that one um
carrie grant plays a young man who goes
to visit his elderly aunts
and they run a rooming house in which
they poison the guests
that's just that's the theme of this
comedy and there's a wonderful spot in
the movie
where carrie grant turns to one of his
aunts to try to understand what's
happening the aunt says oh the gentleman
died because he drank wine that had
poison in it and
cary grant's eyes pop open and he says
but how did the poison get in the wine
that's going to be the title of my
non-existent memoir that's all i ask
myself
so the wine of world peace and discord
and
social peace in the united states has
been poisoned how did the poison get in
the wine
essentially i've devoted my career to
trying to answer
that question
the answers are not to be found uh
just in the last few years
and i want to try to take us back to the
beginnings and a little bit of the story
of how we got to this point that has
been so
aptly described particularly in in that
last speech
we sometimes look for the roots of
america's
reckless intervention in the world in
the period after world war ii
i think that's a mistake that's too late
it actually began before that
you can look at the
period of american imperial expansion
essentially in three sections first we
created a continental empire inside
north america
second in the period around the end of
the 19th century we moved towards
creating
an overseas empire
and then the final phase came after
world war ii when we moved to the idea
of creating global empire
but our first great debate
over whether this was a good idea
took place in the wake of the
spanish-american war
this was a huge debate that involved the
entire united states
and this is something that was new to me
as i began my research from my most
recent book i always understood
that it was the period of the
spanish-american war that led us into
the period of
imperial expansion it was that moment
when we decided
north america is not enough for us we
need to project our coercive and
military power further than that and
that was the period when of course we
took the philippines and guam and puerto
rico and assumed responsibility for cuba
and began setting out on the path that
has led us to where we are now
i had always understood however
that we made this decision more or less
automatically
that it was just the logical next step
we got to california and then the next
step was hawaii and the philippines it
was a sort of a
reasonable
progression
in which the american people were
complicit but actually the opposite is
true the united states erupted in a
nationwide debate over whether this was
a good idea
in the summer of 1898 there was a great
uh
explosion of anti-imperialist
sentiment in the united states
a war that began with the purpose of
liberating cuba turned during that
summer into something very different
suddenly after having sunk the spanish
fleet in the philippines we began to
think maybe we should take the
philippines we should take hawaii we
should replace spain we should join
other european nations in the scramble
for territories and influence around the
world
this created an eruption of protest and
during that year 1898 and through
1899 this was the subject that riveted
the american people i can tell you from
many hours
cranking microfilms in the new york
public library dark room
that this was on the front pages of
every newspaper every day
every major american political
and intellectual leader took sides in
this debate
in the autumn of 1898 president mckinley
decided that he would impose on spain a
treaty by which we would take the
philippines and other uh spanish
possessions and embark on our imperial
project
at this point anti-imperialist sentiment
became intense
an organization called the
anti-imperialist league emerged it had
chapters all around the united states it
staged hundreds of public meetings
distributed hundreds of thousands of
leaflets and broadsides
lobbied intensively in washington
uh
it's a piece of our history that we've
forgotten because i think it's something
that uh maybe we're not
uh told is a good thing for us to
remember
but when you go back and read as i have
the speeches that were made at that time
you can't help but be struck with how
preciated
the anti-imperialists were in those days
let me just give you an example or two
the very first anti-imperialist meeting
in american history
was held on june 15 1898
at faneuil hall in boston
it was exactly on this theme i mentioned
shall we now use the cuban war as an
excuse to become an imperial power
that speech was all that uh rally was
opened by a speech by reverend charles
ames a leading
unitarian theologian
of that era ask yourself how true this
came
the policy of imperialism threatens to
change the temper of our people
and to put us into a permanent attitude
of arrogance testiness and defiance
toward other nations
once we enter the field of international
conflict as a great military and naval
power
we shall be one more bully among bullies
we shall only add one more to the list
of oppressors of mankind
that was 1898
now
that autumn president mckinley decided
that he would proceed with the project
of annexation and world power
he instructed his negotiators in europe
to impose this treaty on
spain and that treaty had to be ratified
by the u.s senate
this set off
a 32-day debate in the senate over
whether this was the right thing to do
or not
other than the time when the founding
fathers gathered to write our
constitution there has never been a
debate in our history when so many
gifted figures came together to debate
so profoundly
an issue so heavily fraught with meaning
for the entire world
some ways i envy
those senators and those americans who
lived then because they had this great
debate
is projecting our military and coercive
power around the world a good thing or
is that a bad thing will it help us will
it help peace or will it undermine peace
this is a debate that we don't have
anymore
that's why i envy them we debate is 3
000 troops the right number for our
surge in afghanistan or 6 000 a better
number
we never debate the larger questions
and here was the last time the united
states did that uh i must say that
going through the debates uh the text of
that 32-day debate is is quite humbling
every issue
on the question of intervention that we
now discuss was first discussed then
so all of american foreign policy can
effectively be reduced down to one
question or down to one word really it's
intervention
where do we intervene when under what
circumstances with what tools with what
goals and that hasn't changed over a
period of more than a hundred years
so
the
arguments that we used on both sides
when we debated as a nation whether to
intervene in vietnam central america
iraq syria are the very same ones that
were used in this debate
uh in the early months of 1899 in the
u.s senate
the one depressing thing about that
debate is that the senators then were so
much more articulate
even the bad guys were brilliant
their speeches are masterpieces of
classical oratory
laced with references to pliny the elder
the cataline conspiracy
things you would never dream of
discussing with a u.s senator today
um
that we that uh debate is so full of
meaning i i want to suggest that somehow
maybe the friends of freedom would like
to publish it uh as a as a pamphlet so
that americans can see how these debates
were so brilliantly argued at that
time i'm not going to go into this in
great depth but let me just to give you
one quick exchange between the two
republican senators from massachusetts
uh henry cabot lodge who was the great
mephistopheles of the imperial project
back then
and his opposite number george frisbie
[ __ ] who was a
outspoken anti-imperialist
and both of these arguments are
arguments you still hear
today here's henry cabot lodge
i do not believe that this nation was
raised up for nothing
i have faith that it has a great mission
in the world
a mission of good
a mission of freedom
i believe it can live up to that mission
therefore i want to see it step forward
boldly and take its place at the head of
nations
this led senator george frisbie [ __ ] to
leap to his feet and reply you have no
right at the cannon's mouth
to impose on an unwilling people your
declaration of independence and your
constitution and your notions of freedom
and what is good
this debate riveted america
foreign diplomats based in washington
were sending back reports every day
about how it was going because all
understood
that this debate was not only going to
shape the united states it was going to
shape the future of the entire world
newspapers were filled with
tallies from day to day how many
senators on this side and that side
which senator has been offered a federal
judgeship in order to vote for the
treaty which by the way he did get
another senator got something even
better than a federal judgeship if
you're a senator which is
the right to name all the postmasters in
your home state
nothing better than that if you're a
senator
uh
so the debate went on as i said for 32
intense days
and the final result was that the u.s
decided
to ratify this treaty meaning not only
as everyone in the senate realized that
we were going to take the philippines
but that we were going to set off
on a new national path
the margin was one vote more than the
required two-thirds majority for that
treaty one
vote
the anti-imperialist then appealed to
the u.s supreme court
they argued first of all that the u.s
government has no powers other than
those specifically granted in the
constitution
and the constitution nowhere says that
the u.s government has the right to send
troops to foreign countries
they also argued that it was not legal
for the u.s to govern people anywhere in
the world without giving them
constitutional rights
which would of course have meant the
instant end of the imperial project
uh the supreme court ruled that uh this
imperial project was legal and
constitutional by a vote of five to four
one vote
uh and interestingly enough the justice
who wrote the majority decision had
recently participated
in the majority decision on the plessy
versus ferguson case which of course uh
ruled that not all americans deserve the
same amount of rights and therefore if
you believe that it's logical to believe
that we don't have to give rights to
people in other countries either
so uh the anti-imperialists were
defeated for a time i think they did
slow down the project don't forget that
in those days we annexed countries we
didn't just govern them and rule them we
took them over we stopped doing that
the philippine war was a huge shock i
think to many americans including
theodore roosevelt who had strongly
promoted it
we truly believed as our leaders told us
that we were going to be welcomed we
were going to have flowers thrown at us
to use the modern term
as we arrived in the philippines things
didn't work out that way
we left over 200 000 filipinos dead
we had our first big torture scandal
uh it was a real loss of innocence for
americans even those that wanted to
ignore what we had done in the mexican
war and what we've done in our wars
against native americans
one of the things i realized from
writing this book was a great discovery
for me the big discovery of my new book
is that this debate ever happened
uh but i learned some other things uh
when writing it and one has to do with
mark twain
so i grew up with what i now realize is
a very partial view of mark twain mr
nice guy everybody loved him he sat on
his front porch he rocked he had nice
white curls and told funny jokes just
like your beloved grandfather
this was not the complete mark twain let
me tell you mark twain was a
vituperative anti-imperialist many of
the uh quotes uh and that i use for mark
twain in my book don't appear
in anthologies or biographies of mark
twain like many people i think he's been
bleached for our public consumption uh
we've taken away the edge
mark twain wrote that american soldiers
fighting in
foreign wars
were carrying a polluted musket under a
bandit's
flag and he even wanted to change the
flag of the united states to replace the
stars with skull and crossbones symbols
i have to tell you in the context of
today when we're looking back to see how
people understood exactly what was going
to happen
uh i have to read you this one little
piece from mark twain which probably you
haven't read since it doesn't appear in
many places after the americans did
through the senate vote decide to pursue
the
career of
uh
international coercive power mark twain
was horrified
mark twain had traveled the world he had
seen the faces of european imperialism
in india and in south africa
he was once invited to be a toastmaster
at a dinner for winston churchill and
after all the other speakers the other
toastmasters spoke about the great
friendship between the u.s and britain
twain got up and said that he had knew
what america had done in the philippines
and he'd seen what the british did in
south africa so he wanted to toast to
british britain and the united states as
truly kin in sin
here is a little script a scrap that
mark twain wrote in his depression over
the us decision to take this imperial
course in the world
ask yourself if this
didn't come true or could it be written
today
it was impossible to save the great
republic she was rotten to the core
lust of conquest had long ago done its
work
trampling upon the helpless abroad
had taught her by natural process to
endure with apathy the like at home
the government was irrevocably in the
hands of the prodigiously rich and their
hangers on
the suffrage was become a mere machine
which they used as they chose
there was no principle but commercialism
no patriotism but of the pocket
1899.
uh
now
uh
the course of the debate
in american history between intervention
and non-intervention
uh between a policy of prudent restraint
and a policy of more aggressive
intervention uh
has been fascinating to follow we've
never
really resolved this debate in fact
sometimes i think americans are not
full-hearted imperialists
we got into this business almost by
accident we never were really sure we
liked it it's not like the british and
the french and the spanish who sat down
and decided we're going to have a world
empire here's how we're going to start
we didn't do it that way and we're still
conflicted
uh
i used to feel that a good analogy for
american the history of american
intervention in the world would be
something like uh let's say a tide that
comes in and goes out that some days we
get very excited about the supposed
wrongs we've suffered in the world and
we want to go out and strike down the
evil doers
then uh
the costs of intervention become clear
the sorrows of empire emerge the body
bags come back and we enter into a
period of more calm
and we don't intervene so much until the
cycle starts again or you could use the
analogy of a pendulum it swings
sometimes we're more this way sometimes
they're more that way but actually the
more i reflect on it
the more i think that those analogies
are inexact in fact we don't swing back
and forth between wanting to intervene
and not wanting to intervene we want to
do both
we hold opposite opinions in our minds
as americans i think americans
really do want every country to
guide itself but we also want to guide
the world
you can't believe both of those things
because they're opposites but we do
forced to make a choice we choose both
and that's the
source of the uh
uncertain policy the united states
follows in the world
in the period after uh
that first burst of imperialism at the
end of the 19th century uh the united
station grabber in american history
moved on to other issues when he became
president after that first intervention
when he seized land for the panama canal
uh he never
ordered another intervention in which a
single life was lost he he began to
understand having promoted the
philippine intervention and seeing the
results
that it would be better for him to spend
his time on other things he moved on to
protecting the environment and
confronting big business the republican
presidents who followed
particularly uh in the teens and
twenties uh were remarkably
non-interventionist the greatest uh
anti-imperialist president the united
states ever had was herbert hoover
hoover takes a bad rap in history
because of his response to the
depression but he was a true
humanitarian whoever had lived in about
a dozen different countries um and saw
the world very much from the perspective
of uh non-americans so uh
that was the moment when the united
states began withdrawing troops from
foreign wars i counted at least six
countries
uh where american companies came to
prison the white house and told them
they've got a problem with the
government in that country and would the
u.s government please intervene and
uh president hoover said no
it will never be
the job of the u.s government to
intervene in a dispute between an
american company and some foreign
government imagine a president saying
that today
um
this of course was all based on the uh
experience of world war one i think this
is another uh intervention that's right
for re-examination
um
world war one is truly the founding
tragedy of our age without world war one
there's no nazis no hitler no holocaust
no communist revolution in russia no
bolshevism
had the united states not intervened in
world war one the war probably would
have dragged on for a couple of more
years and the european powers would have
come up with some settlement in which
some would have gotten some things and
some would have gotten some other things
instead our intervention made sure that
one side achieved total victory and the
other side suffered total defeat and
that led to the unraveling
of the world
to the point that we're seeing it today
now
this same process began
again in the 1930s as world war ii was
shaking europe having been
pulled into one european war uh we were
vulnerable to being pulled into another
one
the united states emerged from world war
ii uh tremendously self-satisfied
the
flood
of books magazine articles uh video
games uh
movies about world war ii it's unending
uh you couldn't fill you'd have more
than enough books to fill this room with
just the
production of one year why is that
well was world war ii a hugely important
episode of course did it shape the
modern world yes
but i think there's another reason
we focus so much on world war ii
world war ii shows the united states the
way we like to think we are
it shows that we went into countries
where there was evil dictatorship
we withdrew we left democracy
we love this story we can't get enough
of it
many other stories come out the other
way
we simply ignore those stories we
pretend that they never happened
and those were some of the stories that
began unfolding in the 1950s
now
as i said it was the period after world
war ii when the united states decided to
take its overseas empire
global
and i think there were a couple of
reasons for that beyond simply world
politics
when i
begin my class at brown every fall in
the history of american intervention
i do point out some factors that shape
world history that i think uh those of
us in the business of analyzing history
underestimate
and one of them is
the private psychology of individuals
i think this played a great deal into
the role of the founding of the security
state in the united states in this way
uh during the world war ii as you all
know the u.s had
an intelligence agency the oss the
office of strategic services
alan dulles was of course one of the
leading figures of the oss he headed the
uh
station in switzerland uh ran operations
all over europe
uh after the war was over
uh they wanted to continue their
operations in europe in fact alan dulles
had applied to become head of the oss in
all of europe
uh bill donovan the head of it didn't
think much of alan dulles's
administrative abilities so wouldn't
give him that job
but agreed to make him head of the oss
station in
berlin
uh only a few days after alan dulles got
there to take over this job president
harry truman abolished the oss
and alan dulles had to go home
he had to go back to work for his
brother's law firm again which he didn't
like
all the other oss officers had to go
back home and would go back home at back
to the investment bank
uh back to the law firm
back to wall street
back to the people you went to princeton
with and you went to show it with
uh and they weren't happy they had been
living at an adrenaline life right on
the edge of excitement and death
they were like the british pilots
during the battle of britain
who were going to be dead from moment to
moment and suddenly they're back
delivering milk in bristol
uh
people like alan dulles could not handle
this transition they spent countless
hours
talking about how to get back in the
business
how can we get back to doing something
like we used to do which was so much fun
and we saved the world
well one way to do it was to promote the
idea that there was a threat out there
just as great as the threat that was
posed by nazi germany and imperial japan
they heavily promoted that idea
and uh
alan dulles was then a co-author
of the bill the national security act of
1947 that created the cia
as was referred to
here already uh
it was created in a very special way and
it's like this is so important i need to
repeat it it had always been the rule of
western intelligence services
to separate intelligence gathering
from
covert action you don't want to have the
two in the same agency otherwise every
intelligence report logically ends with
the conclusion so we need a covert
operation
alan dulles broke down that wall which
was famously observed by the uh british
secret service always thought to have
been the gold standard in that business
so alan dulles wrote a bill creating an
agency the cia that would do both it
would do intelligence gathering but also
act on intelligence a
really a
dramatic and fateful change
um
alan dulles then
maneuvered himself into the new c.i.a
very quickly
and
brought a number of the old oss men with
him including his former deputy from
switzerland richard helms
they moved into the cia together
and as you all know uh alan dulles then
became head of the cia under eisenhower
in 1953. now
eisenhower
had a very important role in the
foundation of the situation that we're
talking about right now
it was not known at the time nor could
it have been but eisenhower was a fierce
supporter
of the idea of covert action
he loved the idea of using the cia to
overthrow foreign governments
um
now he never explained why he so
strongly supported covert action
uh because he never admitted that there
was any
uh in fact in his memoir he lies
specifically and explicitly about what
he knew and what he did uh he would have
said i'm sure if we could bring him back
now those weren't lies
i was protecting national security
uh
so why what what would he say if he
could come back and and be honest with
us
uh about why he supported these covert
operations i think one thing he would
have told us is that from his point of
view
covert action was a peace project
don't forget eisenhower had to
send kids off to die by the thousands
in world war ii this must have weighed
on him
when alan dulles came to him with this
idea i can overthrow foreign government
and get rid of your problem in country x
for just a few dollars and hardly anyone
will die
it sounded great to eisenhower he felt
that he had saved lives on both sides so
you definitely resolve a problem and uh
you do it without excessive bloodshed
now
um
this was a great uh
fantasy and i think this might have been
the second thing that eisenhower might
tell us now
what he would have said if he was being
honest
when i started authorizing covert
operations to overthrow governments in
foreign countries this was a new project
we never had to do this before in the
old days when we wanted to overthrow a
government we just landed the marines
we couldn't do that anymore because the
red army was out there
so we had this new technique of
uh covert action
and it had never been done before
so i didn't understand
what the long-term implications might be
i thought you just do it and it's over
now in the writing business we're always
taught to avoid cliches but like in
every business we do have some cliches
that guide our own writing
one cliche writers often throw around is
every story is either happy or sad
depending on where you end it
boy does this work for covert action
um
let's take our first uh covert action in
the dulles eisenhower era 1953 mossad
deck in iran
actually eisenhower did not come into
office with any anti-musa deck feelings
later he became a great promoter of
covert action and reprimanded alan
dulles for
saying that burning the cuban sugar
fields would work with castor he wanted
something more something bigger and
eisenhower went on to become the first
and possibly only president to authorize
the assassination of foreign leaders but
in the early days he didn't come in with
any feelings against mossada
but the dulles brothers did
uh
john foster dulles was the senior
partner at sullivan and cromwell the law
firm that represented most of the major
american multinational corporations
um one of those corporations uh was the
schroeder bank which was the financial
agent for the anglo-iranian oil company
a long-time client of sullivan and
cromwell and of course
dulles would have realized that if musa
deck in iran could get away with
nationalizing his country's main
resource
other countries might want to
nationalize their own resources and this
could upset the whole way the world is
run
therefore
john foster dulles was particularly
eager to overthrow moses deck alan
dulles had his own motivation
alan dulles's greatest success in his
legal career was getting the shah of
iran to sign on to what was then the
largest development project in world
history in which a consortium of
american engineering firms would come to
iran and completely transform the
country
a musta deck in his national front
killed that project
and alan dulles didn't forget that
either so they came in with the desire
to overthrow mosaic deck mossad
and they persuaded eisenhower to do it
in fact we can now follow the
process by which this coup was approved
through the
declassified documents there's only one
moment
when any
member of the us government
expresses any doubt and it's eisenhower
himself they're in a meeting of the
national security council
and eisenhower says something like i'm
glad we're getting rid of this communist
massa deck
but i didn't even know he was a
communist
and in fact most of the deck was an
elderly feudal landlord who despised all
socialist ideas
um and john foster dulles had the great
answer oh you're right he's not a
communist but
uh iran is a big country it's right on
the border of the soviet union it has a
lot of oil mossadeck is old he's sick he
could die there's a communist party in
iran it's too dangerous a situation to
be allowed to continue and eisenhower
agreed went ahead and launched that
operation as you all know from reading
an interesting book about it
it only took kermit roosevelt three
weeks
in the summer of 1953 to throw iran into
complete chaos and organize a project by
which moses dick was overthrown so if
you could stop history right there
it seemed like the perfect ending
we got rid of a guy we didn't like
mozart deck
and we replaced him with a guy the shah
who would do whatever we wanted
sounded like the perfect ending
but history doesn't stop
and
you can trace that forward now to today
the shah that we placed back in power
ruled with increasing repression for 25
years his repression produced the
explosion of the late 1970s what we call
the islamic revolution that brought to
power a clique of fanatically
anti-american mullahs who have spent
decades working intently and sometimes
quite violently
to undermine american interests all over
the world
that revolution also emboldened iran's
enemy saddam hussein next door to invade
iran we were so angry at iran
for overthrowing our shah and the
hostage crisis that we embraced saddam
we provided him with help in his war
against iran that was the beginning of
our spiral down into the iraq disaster
we're still in
uh
that revolution of 1979 also terrified
the soviets who thought that radical
islam would now be penetrating through
their
southern border that was one of the
motivations that led them
to invade afghanistan that's what
brought us into our death cycle in
afghanistan from which we're still not
able to extract ourselves and our
confrontation with iran continues to
be a major part of our foreign policy so
a lot of history unfolded
from three weeks in the summer of 1953.
alan dulles and eisenhower followed this
path relentlessly through the 1950s the
very next year after overthrowing uh
mossad deck their next target was arbenz
in guatemala who had the temerity to
propose a land reform law that affected
the interests of united fruit company
one of the oldest
and most faithful clients of sullivan
and cromwell the dulles brothers had
personally been in guatemala working for
the united fruit company and arranging
its uh
contracts with past dictators so they
wanted to get rid of him for those
reasons that stem directly from that so
why do we carry out these operations
what is the motivation
is it really strategic that we feel
we're under threat from a foreign enemy
or is it economic is it business
the more i try to parse this the more i
realize the two of them go very closely
together
so we look at somebody like arbenz or
moza deck or later on
sukarno
lumumba so many other third world
leaders and we say these people are not
uh
so are not on board with our foreign
policy particularly they're bothering
american companies
that it always starts with that there's
some corporation that has a problem with
the local government this corporation
then goes to the u.s government and asks
for help
it's there that the motivation changes
the u.s government does not intervene in
order to protect the rights of
corporations they convince themselves or
we let's put it ourselves we as the u.s
we convince ourselves that the only
reason
the government of country x would be
bothering an american company like
trying to nationalize resources or
trying to impose a labor code
would be that they're strategically
anti-american they're in league with our
enemies that's the reason we want to
overthrow them not because they're
bothering the companies
it's because they're against us
geopolitically how do we know they're
against us geopolitically because
they're bothering american companies
so the motivation morphs a little bit
but remains essentially the same
now
this policy of intervention reached a
peak under eisenhower uh with the
two orders to assassinate castro and
assassinate lumumba as far as we know
these are the only two
orders that came from a president uh to
assassinate foreign leaders uh
the church committee later uh came up
with a great word to describe
how eisenhower ordered these uh
assassinations i don't know if this one
would get through your spell check he's
he ordered them
circumlocutiously
i want that guy sawed off
it's pretty circum locutious
uh so
we carried out these assassination
projects as ways to promote
the
uh same
regime change operations that we hadn't
been involved with all over the world
all of these are motivated by the idea
that our sphere of influence includes
the whole world
uh james bond
was a great influence on alan dulles and
on president kennedy unfortunately
i think one of the
the great long lessons that james bond
teaches us is that one guy can go out
and solve a big world problem and
there's never any repercussions
you close the book and the story's over
i think kennedy may have fantasized this
himself don't forget kennedy was also
the guy who increased our troop strength
in vietnam from 800 to 16 000. he was
the person who named the chief law
enforcement officer of the united states
robert kennedy to coordinate a process
to assassinate
leaders in foreign countries
uh
all of this has led us
to the belief we have today that we must
be involved in every conflict in the
world and that we're good at it we'll
improve things
there doesn't seem to be any limit to
the number of times these operations can
go wrong before we question whether they
are wise or not
now i mentioned that when i was writing
my book about that first debate back in
1898 i made this discovery that the
debate ever happened and
also a little bit about mark twain
as often happens uh
when you're embarked on projects like
this you make other discoveries i
discovered a great american
who i had known something about
but not much
william graham sumner
he's in one of the books you've just
been given he wrote a wonderful essay
which is in that book called the
conquest of the united states by spain
in which he argues that we we defeated
them militarily but they defeated us
by forcing us to adopt their oppressive
colonial mentality
william graham sumner was the founder
founder of uh sociology as a discipline
not incidentally he's the uh
inventor of the term ethnocentrism
so i just want to close by reading you a
speech that he made in 1898
and ask you to reflect on its relevance
the great foe of democracy now and in
the near future is
plutocracy
every year that passes brings out this
antagonism more distinctly
it is to be the social war of the 20th
century
in that war
militarism
expansion
and imperialism
will all
favor plutocracy
therefore
expansion and imperialism are a grand
onslaught on democracy
thank you
uh
yes okay people are moving around
douglas p horn our next speaker served
as head of the military records team on
the assassination records review board
the independent federal agency
established by congress in the 1990s to
secure release of the long secret
official records relating to the
assassination of president john f
kennedy the arrb of course was was
formed in response to the public outcry
over the secrecy of records as reflected
in
john in oliver stone's movie jfk
horn played an instrumental role in
locating and securing the release of u.s
military records on cuba and vietnam
policy from 1961
through 1964.
he is the author of the five volume book
which is absolutely fantastic and which
really was an eye-opener for me
uh called the uh inside the
assassination records review board the
us government's final attempt to
reconcile the conflicting medical
evidence and the assassination of jfk
and the author of fff's best-selling
e-book jfk's war with the national
security establishment why kennedy was
assassinated
he also made a six and a half hour video
presentation entitled altered history
exposing deceit and deception in the jfk
assassination evidence for the future of
freedom foundation which has now
received 240
000 views
his most recent view
book
deception intrigue and the road to war
is about fdr and pearl harbor the title
of doug's book is the national security
establishment's obsession with invading
castro's cuba
1960-63
the bay of pigs northwoods and beyond
please welcome my friend douglas horn
[Applause]
okay can everybody hear me good
it's a great honor to be part of this
conference thank you jacob
and thank you to the future freedom
foundation
now my presentation is very heavy on
text as my presentations always are so
uh
because of time limitations today
i'm sure i will not be able to cover
each point on each slide in the detail
that i might normally like so
when you notice me summarizing something
rather briefly or perhaps moving to
another slide
or skipping one or two items please keep
in mind that this will be online this
this presentation will be online in four
or five weeks probably
perhaps even sooner and there will be
this visual record of the powerpoint so
you'll be able to go back and
read all of this text in detail thank
you
this slide is an overview of what you're
going to hear today in this
uh presentation
from august of 60 until december of 63
the national security establishment was
obsessed
with invading cuba and left a
considerable paper trail documenting
this
now by november and december of 1960 the
cia knew that its exile invasion which
later took place at the bay of pigs
could not succeed
without overt u.s military intervention
but nevertheless continued planning for
it on the assumption that overt us
military intervention would be provided
when it began to fail
jfk had warned openly that he would not
allow u.s military forces to participate
in a cuban invasion
but the cia and the pentagon did not
believe him
and were mistakenly convinced he could
be leveraged if and when the invasion
began to falter
and of course the invasion faltered and
failed it was the perfect failure we'll
talk about this in a minute
now operation mongoose was established
on november 30th of 1961
and its goal was to sponsor
psychological and economic pressure
sabotage and military
paramilitary operations against cuba and
the goal was to bring down the castro
regime
everybody in this room probably knows
that
but some of you may not know is that
stimulated by the mongoose operations
officer
brigadier general landsdale of the air
force
in march 1962
the pentagon proposed numerous pretexts
for instigating
a u.s military invasion of cuba
dubbed operation northwoods
and this plan
stimulated by lansdale and submitted by
lemniter
was rejected by jfk that same month
so in april of 1962 the very next month
the joint chiefs of staff
wrote a blistering tutorial to secretary
of defense mcnamara demanding that the
united states invade cuba and no longer
mentioning pretexts they said we have to
do this anyway and we have to do it
right now
well that did not happen
now as you all know during the missile
crisis
in the in october of 62 jfk prepared for
and considered possible air strikes
and a massive invasion
but eventually resolved the crisis
through diplomacy
infuriating the military intelligence
establishment
an informal no invasion pledge was
publicly made by the kennedy
administration in november of 1962
in exchange for
now no reintroduction
of offensive weapons into cuba by the
ussr
and what surprised me
as i was writing my volume five of my
book inside the arrb was that
throughout 1963
the pentagon continued to study the use
of pretext as an excuse to invade cuba
and actually planned an invasion for
1964.
and the person behind that was
kennedy's most trusted general general
maxwell taylor which is still very
disturbing to me
at the same time taylor is
engaged in this activity in the pentagon
the u.s government is trying to hammer
out a formal
new policy on cuba
and basically the state department does
not favor
unilateral military intervention and the
pentagon does and in the long run when
they come up with a new policy at the
end of october 63 the state department
has lost the battle
we'll talk about that in more detail
now remarkably all of the above pressure
to overthrow the castro government
by unilateral u.s military action took
place in an environment where the u.s
commander-in-chief president kennedy
strongly opposed any u.s invasion of
cuba with the u.s military
it is a remarkable example of a national
security establishment
determined to see its will prevail over
a non-cooperative chief executive
only with jfk's assassination in 1963
and lyndon johnson's immediate focus on
vietnam instead of cuba
did this pressure to invade cuba subside
and wither away
so this is our topic today
there are implications of this struggle
which i'll
which i hope to reach at the end of the
presentation
if i don't run out of time
so the bay of pigs what became the bay
of pigs was born in march of 1960 when
eisenhower
approved
covert actions against the castro regime
there was no mention yet of
us military invasion at least not
overtly but paramilitary operations were
envisaged
so the actual uh permission
excuse me the actual
yeah permission to conduct paramilitary
ops and invade cuba with cuban exiles uh
was issued on in august of 1960 by
president eisenhower
his main concern was plausible
deniability
so the initial plans only envisaged
using about 500
cuban exiles
and that and the key thing about this
plan was that
it had to stimulate
an internal uprising that was absolutely
essential to its success this was the
planning the thinking in august of 1960.
just to keep yourself apprised of what
else was going on in august of 1960 that
same month the cia began to enlist the
american mafia to assassinate castro
now this is important and this comes
from john newman's new book countdown to
darkness number two in his three book
series about the assassination i highly
recommend it
on november 3rd of 1960 in a national
security council meeting
the pentagon the state department and
the national security advisor
had already dismissed the internal
uprising myth they knew it was not going
to happen
castro's police force was too large his
army was too large and his control of
the populace
was
was well established and he was popular
here's the quote from john newman's book
this is from the minutes of the nsc
meeting quote
mr gray that's eisenhower's nsa
expressed the opinion that we will never
be able to clean up the situation
without the use of overt us military
force he suggested the possibility of
using the cia-backed exiles to mount a
simulated attack
on guantanamo
in order to offer an excuse for overt
intervention end quote
so this is the first mention of the
possible use of pretexts
to invade cuba
now although this didn't happen at that
time this idea remained alive within the
u.s government
and uh actually dominated planning in
1962-3
the use of pretexts
here's another quote from john newman's
book on november 15 1960 in a in a c i a
western hemisphere 4 meeting
this quote is from a report they issued
from
the meeting
and that report of their meeting quotes
another document which we don't have yet
in full but this is the quote they put
in their own report from this meeting
our original concept
is now seen to be unachievable
in the face of the controls castro has
instituted there will not be the
internal unrest earlier believed
possible nor will the defenses permit
the type of strike first plan
our second concept
of fifteen hundred to three thousand men
uh securing a beach with an airstrip
is also now seen to be unachievable
except as a joint agency dod action
so nobody in the us government who knows
anything at this time believes that the
bay of pigs or at the time it was called
pluto
would succeed on its own that the exiles
would succeed nobody believes that
and as john newman states this is a
rosetta stone to understanding what
happened in the coming months
jfk was repeatedly falsely informed by
the cia that the exile invasion would
indeed stimulate a widespread internal
uprising in cuba
that would lead to castro's downfall and
they knew it wasn't true
and the reason they lied to the
president
is because if they
told him that they knew the whole
operation would be canceled he did not
favor
any u.s invasion of cuba
so president kennedy was briefed twice
right after the election by dulles and
bissell the first time i think it was
november the 18th
we don't have a documentary record of
what was said but we do have a record of
what was said on november 29th
and uh here's what happened uh
bissell told the president that
uh a significant strike force
that's the cuban exiles would act as a
catalyst and ultimately provoking an
anti-castro uprising on the island
this lie is repeated and maintained ever
after by the cia in all subsequent
presidential planning sessions for the
exile invasion
on january 3rd 1960 president eisenhower
raises the subject of pretexts which his
national security advisor had raised the
previous year
and eisenhower said
quote perhaps we could think of
manufacturing something that would be
generally acceptable
and you know he said if end quote and if
we had a if he had a really good excuse
he'd send in u.s troops then but he
didn't have a really good excuse
so that idea
is
remains alive within the us government
and uh
basically
takes over u.s planning in 62 and 63 the
use of pretexts
on january 11th the pentagon is briefed
by the cia and the exile invasion and
general gray of the joint staff
tells the chiefs that
only u.s over only overt u.s military
intervention can overthrow castro that
the exile invasion alone cannot succeed
the joint chiefs know this
on january 22nd lumnitzer reveals to the
new secretary of state that
castro has an army of 32 thousand men a
police force of 9 000 men and a militia
of 200 000 men
and had been receiving large amounts of
supplies from the ussr
which was making the exile invasion
obviously seem more and more dubious
so president kennedy's first big meeting
on this subject is january 28th
and this is the one moment when the
joint chiefs tell the president the
truth
dulles reports to the president at this
meeting
that the pentagon's position was that no
currently authorized course of action
could succeed in overthrowing the castro
regime
and of course this was true
and lemnitzer confirmed this by saying
that in spite of the cia's optimistic
view about the chances for the exiles to
land and hold the beachhead soon after
they landed castro would bring in
superior forces
and the question would then be who would
come to their aid
and as newman puts it the president did
not bite this
told everyone in the room that the
president was not interested in us
military intervention in cuba
so
just six days later
the joint chiefs flipped
and submitted
a formal evaluation of the paramilitary
plan to invade cuba
and said quote in summary evaluation of
the current plan results in a favorable
assessment
the report is full of individual
shortcomings
and yet overall they viewed it favorably
quote
timely execution of this plan has a fair
chance of ultimate success
now after the bay pigs failed
and maxwell taylor came out of
retirement to investigate what had
happened for the president
it was determined that the chiefs really
felt that the plan only had a 30 percent
chance of success and a 70 percent
chance of failure
and yet they said fair chance of success
by the way after the site was changed
from trinidad to
the bay of pigs they then thought it was
20 80
20 chance of success and 80
of failure
so on march 11 president kennedy
disapproves operation pluto because he
doesn't like the site at trinidad it's
too noisy it's too public
he's obsessed with plausible deniability
as was eisenhower
and on march 15th the bay of pigs
is presented as the new site invade at
the bay of pigs invade the playa geron
peninsula
with approximately fifteen hundred men a
little bit less than fifteen hundred
the joint chiefs of staff approve this
plan also
so on april 4th president kennedy
approves the
invasion and is scheduled to begin on or
about the 15th to the 17th of april
to his credit he directs that the cuban
exile brigade leaders be informed that
u.s military forces would not be allowed
to participate in the invasion he wanted
those people told
in any way
that speaks well for the president
and john newman pointed this out in his
new book and i did not know this until i
read countdown to darkness the
president's continued insistence on
plausible deniability
causes secretary of state dean rusk
to gradually whittle down the size and
number of airstrikes before the invasion
these are the cuban exile airstrikes
flying out of guatemala
to whittle down the size and number of
airstrikes but no one at any of the
planning meetings informs the president
about how essential they consider the
planned air strikes are to success
we all know the bay of pigs was the
perfect failure
president kennedy resisted repeated
requests by the cia and the pentagon
to save the invasion with u.s military
intervention
he had told them privately before the
invasion that there would be no u.s
military intervention and
he had also stated so publicly
when castro started screaming about what
was about to happen
uh
president kennedy went on television and
said there will be no us military
involved in invading cuba so he decided
to keep his promise about that and not
be a liar
and to take one on the chin and to deal
with castro later
he also
was not in favor of uh
trying to save a hopeless and doomed
exile invasion with ill-advised ad-hoc
incremental and piecemeal u.s military
actions
and he also knew he'd been set up
as david talbot put it in his book the
devil's chess board the bay of pigs was
quote
not simply simply doomed to fail it was
meant to fail end quote
meant to fail to suck the president and
get him to commit u.s military forces
now john newman has
published many eloquent comments about
the bay of pigs in his new book
countdown to darkness i'm just going to
read the last one
quote president kennedy had made it
clear to his subordinates
that he would not under any
circumstances commit u.s military forces
to action in cuba
yet dulles and the chiefs did not
believe their commander-in-chief
they were certain that once the exile
brigade was pinned down and being
slaughtered on the beach head kennedy
would have to give in
the chiefs had lied about their
professional position
on the cia plan it was a disgraceful
disloyal and insubordinate performance
end quote
so once maxwell taylor completed his
review of the debacle
president kennedy motored over to the
pentagon on may 27th and scolded the
chiefs of staff to their faces
that cannot have been a pleasant meeting
for anyone
told them how dissatisfied he had been
with their recent advice on cuba and
laos which were characterized by poor
staff work and narrow-minded blindered
recommendations that failed to consider
international or global strategic
considerations
and then this meeting in person was
followed on
june 28th by three
national security action memos which
many of you have heard of
55 56 and 57
55 was a personal scolding directly to
the joint
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff lemnitzer
i expect the joint chiefs of staff to
present the military viewpoint and
governmental councils in such a way as
to ensure that the military factors are
clearly understood before decisions are
reached
i regard the chiefs to be more than
military men and expect their health and
fitting military requirements into the
overall context of any situation
the third in sam issue that day 57
said that the cia can no longer conduct
paramilitary paramilitary operations
unless they're small in size and within
their scope and can remain wholly
disavowable and holy covert
and that any large
paramilitary operations in the future
would be the responsibility of the
pentagon
so mongos is approved on november 30th
1961.
it's political psychological economic
and covert actions
uh designed to bring down the castro
regime while cont simultaneously
continuing jc is planning for decisive
u.s capability for intervention
it's a two-tier
committee the special group augmented of
the national security council includes
the heavy hitters
robert kennedy maxwell taylor
now maxwell taylor is not chairman of
the jcs yet he's still president
kennedy's personal military advisor
lyman lemnitzer he's chairman of the jcs
john mccone
you alexis johnson and roswell
kilpatrick who's deputy sexdev
the weekly meetings were attended by
two notable people in american cuban
history william harvey
the father of the executive action
assassination program and
general lansdale the operations officer
lansdale is the glue that holds mongers
together
and
this is what we're going to be
discussing in the next several slides
an obsession with invading cuba using
american armed forces grips the pentagon
in the spring of 1962. here's the
timeline
on january 17th lansdale requests that
the joint staff
prepare a policy statement on cuba they
responded on february 7th
we'll look at that statement in just a
moment
lansdale on march the 5th requested that
general craig of the joint staff provide
a brief but precise brief but precise
description of pretexts
which would provide justification for
u.s military intervention in cuba
and he wants the answer by march 13th
on march 13th these pretexts
were signed out by
jcs chairman lemnitzer and sent to
secretary of defense mcnamara
and
we'll review these in just a moment in
detail
on the 16th
the idea of invading cuba
with u.s military was rejected by the
president and the idea of the use of
pretext was rejected by the president
in a meeting which we'll be discussing
on april 10th
the chiefs fought back and sent this
blistering memo to mcnamara demanding
that cuba be invaded and that it be done
in the near future there was no mention
of pretext anymore and that advice was
not followed
now i'm very proud to be able to say
that it was the
review board that got the northwoods
file of these pretexts
shaken loose from the pentagon the joint
staff secretariat
faithfully complied with our search
requests
and handed this over to me
in 1997 and the
military records team got it
declassified in record time and we've
released the documents that year
if there had been no jfk records act
that you would not know anything about
northwoods
and if there had been
no jfk movie
if there'd been no jfk movie by oliver
stone there would have been no jfk
records act
okay let's not forget that
so this policy statement
produced in response to line sales
request
uh
provided a lot of information but i want
you to focus on the first two the
soviets could establish land sea or air
bases in cuba and specifically the
second one the nightmare scenario the
soviets could provide castro with a
number of ballistic missiles with
nuclear warheads
so for these reasons the policy
statement says the
existence of the
of a communist cuba regime is
incompatible with our requirements in
the western hemisphere
and they're prepared to act
they list conditions necessary to
support a successful u.s military
intervention in cuba
the first three are supposed to go
together
there has to appear to be an urgent
humanitarian requirement to restore
order
uh the united states and and or the oas
have to announce that we're moving into
cuba to restore order and hold free
elections
and this should be happened so quickly
that the communist bloc
doesn't have time to react elsewhere in
the world
or
and this big ore is the telegraph they
had already figured out what they wanted
to do
by the time these guys answered
lansdale's request
this is what they wanted to do or the
cuban regime commits hostile acts
against u.s forces or property which
would serve as an incident upon which to
base overt u.s intervention
so that ore is the condition necessary
to support a u.s invasion
so as i said lansdale requested pretexts
on march the 5th
the joint chiefs considered this request
two days later and provided a green
light
and just two days later after after that
on march the 9th
the joint staff came up with a pretext
i think they were sitting on go when
they got the request
so this is the green light that the
joint chiefs gave to the study if you
look at the second one
it says in red determination that a
creditable internal revolt is impossible
of attainment
sick
during the next nine to ten months will
require a decision by the united states
to develop a cuban provocation as
justification for positive us military
action so this is the green light
given by the joint chiefs to the joint
staff to come up with these pretexts
the the pretext were generated on march
9th by the joint staff and on on march
13th just a few days later
they were approved and full without any
changes by the
chiefs and signed out by lyman
leminitzer
and sent to mcnamara
they included the following pretext for
war
so all of these were false incidents in
guantanamo bay naval base
which they were proposing fake an attack
on the base blow up ammunition on the
base blame it on castro sabotage a ship
in the hammer
with fires sink a ship near the harbor
entrance a remember the main incident
they used that language
and conduct mock funerals afterwards
this one's
very disturbing the next one
develop and implement a communist cuban
terror campaign in the united states in
miami and other florida cities even in
washington d.c
in which the targets could be
anti-castro cuban refugees seeking haven
in the united states the exploding of
real bombs could be engineered and
attempts on the lives of cuban refugees
could be staged even to include wounding
and false documents would be released to
prove that castro did it all
this is a really stupid one
a u.s jet such as an f-86 that's a
korean war fighter plane short stubby
fighter plane
could be painted like a cuban mig and
simulate an air attack on a u.s airliner
that one falls apart as soon as somebody
takes a picture out the window and
develops the picture and they notice oh
that's not a mig that's an f-86
this is the scary one
it's a lot of words i'll just tell you
about it
the idea was to take a cia-owned
airliner
owned by a cia charter company
turn it into a drone remotely piloted
which could be blown up over cuba
and uh
it would take off from eglin air force
base
at the right time
be blown up over cuba after tape
recordings were played from the
airplane's radio we're being attacked
we're being attacked help us and then it
would blow up
the right time would be
after another airplane painted exactly
the same
would take off with fake passengers on
board real people
pretending to be passengers these would
be covert operatives land secretly at
eglin air force base deplaying the
passengers then the drone would take off
and go get blown up over cuba
nobody's ever explained to me how this
story is going to stand up when there
are no bodies found
think about that
there probably would have been an
international investigation there would
have been no bodies but these people
were serious about this
and the last one we'll talk about a
submarine u.s submarine would deposit
parts from a
destroyed in quotes a destroyed us
fighter plane
and claim it was shot down by the cubans
and this would involve
a pilot leaving formation without the
other pilots knowing what was happening
he would leave the formation
claim he was being shot down he would
disappear
and go back to his normal job
i'm going to leave you with one thought
after world war ii
we prosecuted people
at nuremberg for
a conspiracy to make aggressive war
that's what this is a conspiracy to make
war
[Applause]
and there's only one reason it wasn't
done and that's john f kennedy
who reject who rejected the idea of the
use of pretext
on march 16 62
i'm not going to read all of these
points to you you can read these later
online
it was brought up at a meeting by
lemnancer kennedy rejected the idea of
pretexts and also rejected the idea of
invading with us forces even if there
were a popular revolt in cuba he says
we're not going to invade cuba
end of subject
lansdale took the minutes and they
weren't declassified until march 28
2005.
so i'm really happy that
david talbot put all that in his book
his book brothers
i've mentioned that the joint chiefs
fought back and wrote a strong april
memo
to mcnamara saying we need to invade
cuba now
and they think it can be done without
risk of general war that's the euphemism
for worldwide nuclear conflict
they think it can be done without the
risk of general war they do state
continued police action would be
required that's an understatement
and they want it done as soon as
possible before the reserves go home
it didn't happen
so why did the soviet union put
oh boy i better speed up why did the
soviet union put missiles in cuba
they were very aware of their strategic
nuclear inferiority
and uh they wanted to defend their
socialist communist ally
and they had misjudged president kennedy
as a weak leader
based on bay of pigs and the vienna
summit
and they thought he could be rolled
so during the crisis i'm sure you all
know that
the consensus position of the joint
chiefs and the ca was in support of
bombing and invading cuba to remove the
medium-range ballistic missiles
however jfk chose blockade in concert
with a threat of airstrikes and invasion
and strong diplomatic pressure
the hard-liners the pentagon and the cia
were of the opinion that the president
could no longer refuse
to take direct military action
and that the u.s no longer needed any
pretext
for invasion since a bona fide reason
indeed an imperative had presented
itself
after the crisis was resolved through
diplomacy
president kennedy met with the chiefs to
thank them for their advice there had
been considerable friction with him
during the crisis he said gentlemen
we've won
you know we've won i know we've won but
i don't want anyone anyone to gloat
about it
the responses were
george anderson chief of naval
operations we've been had
the may exploded
one hell we lost it's the greatest
defeat in our history we should go in
and wipe them out today end quote
and of course the tapes reveal that
during the crisis
directly to president kennedy on october
19th lemay said this is almost as bad as
the appeasement at munich
and you're in a pretty bad fix
so throughout 1963 uh two things are
going on
the government's trying to come up with
a new cuba policy
because mongoose was a dead program at
this point it was dead
and while the government is holding
interdepartmental meetings maxwell
taylor is planning to invade
using pretext and he's planning to
invade in 1964.
let me see if i can speed this up
these are taylor's own words when he
commissioned this study of the invasion
plan for 64. quote consideration should
be given to the advantages of
engineering an incident as a cause for
invasion
end quote because he knows there's not
going to be
a spontaneous revolt in cuba
they send his own
assumptions back to him as a policy
statement the joint staff very loyal
and uh
at the bottom of the slide you'll see
the conclusion section states u.s should
create a pretext for overt u.s military
intervention in cuba
and launched military action to remove
the castro government this is amazing to
me
kennedy rejected pretext on march 1662
and decided not to invade even during
the missile crisis and then issued a no
invasion cuba
and launched military action to remove
the castro government this is amazing
now the invasion plan for 64 which uh
sink land came up with
uh included many steps i'm going to just
read you three of the milestones
the state department's job is to come up
with a free cuban government
that's what they were supposed to do
before the bay of pigs too
they're supposed to insert them about
july 15 64.
about the time they begin to mobilize
the us military for the invasion
listen to this folks
on cuban independence day that's the
equivalent of our july the 4th
a surprise airstrike would be launched
against cuba by the united states
the invasion would take place
about august 3rd
and the assumption was that
uh by october 1st
note that's a month before the election
in 64.
it would all be over
this was mysteriously withdrawn from
consideration
on october 4th 63. we don't specifically
know why
i'm planning to launch a devastating
surprise
air attack on the cuban independence day
was unbelievably tone deaf to say the
least
we don't know why taylor is doing this
presumably he's acting on his own this
is one of the slides i'll encourage you
to read later when this is this
presentation is online
the icca was the interdepartmental
coordinating committee on cuban affairs
it's too hard to say that so we call it
icca
this
ad hoc committee met
all year long
and it was basically state cia and
pentagon
those were the main agencies involved
the state precondition and the kennedy's
precondition in setting their charter
was that invasion by the u.s would not
be undertaken in the absence of
aggression that threatens the peace and
security of the western hemisphere so
they were not to start with the
assumption that the u.s would invade but
what will our policy be
the policy was still to be to remove
castro okay
the hawks on the committee
are hawks studying the work of the
committee people like paul netzie elmo
zumwalt
and the joint chiefs themselves
eventually hijacked
this
committee and
came up with a resolution that did
indeed authorize massive u.s military
intervention as the u.s policy as the
new u.s policy if it was preceded by a
u.s instigated coup in cuba
which would give the military action
legitimacy
so
the final draft of this plan
which was sent back to taylor by cyrus
vance on october 30th
started out sounding very
high-minded and
everything that the president had
initially wanted
quote the u.s does not contemplate
either a premeditated full-scale
invasion of cuba except in the case of
soviet intervention or the
reintroduction of nuclear weapons
or the contrivance of a provocation
which could be used as a pretext for
such action that sounds great that's
what president kennedy wanted them to
take as their
founding guidelines but as you read the
draft as you continue to read it
it turns out that that was just window
dressing
because the whole plan
and i encourage you to read this later
online the whole plan
was to
insert
a new government into cuba
selected by us of course
insert a special team along with them
which within one day 24 hours that's a
joke would make a decision on whether or
not
cuba was ready for the invasion in other
words
would the new government we inserted be
able to instigate a coup would they be
able to take over the government
and if they were able to do so
the coup leaders would publicly proclaim
a provisional government and openly
request u.s and oas assistance the
president would then announce isolation
of cuba by aaron c blockade
and then we would invade using the same
op lands that we were going to use
during the missile crisis
presumably
this
coup in cuba which was what they called
this plan
would have been would have involved an
assassination presumably
so
this staged or engineered coup
probably engineered by csa cia
assassination
and
the immediate insertion of a new cuban
government was nothing more in my view
than a pretext so
this idea would not go away
extreme bitterness and deep hatred for
jfk over u.s foreign policy direction
existed within key elements of the
national security state the pentagon and
the cia
following the end of the cuban missile
crisis this is john newman's language
and i
couldn't think of a better way to say it
so i used his language extreme
bitterness and deep hatred for the
president
i believe that widespread anger within
the establishment over president
kennedy's desire not to invade cuba
prior to the missile crisis and his
refusal to do so during the crisis was
surely the proximate cause of his
assassination
now other events during 63 surely uh
stiffen the resolve of the coop ladders
i'm talking about the u.s coupe plotters
that removed president kennedy
to do what they wanted to do
asking the fbi to shut down the training
camps for for cuban exiles uh
the peace speech
the nuclear test ban treaty
and then his attempt
for a rapprochement with castro in
september and october of 63 all of those
things i'm sure and especially the
decision to withdraw from vietnam in
october which i know jim will talk about
later today
in sam 263 those
additional decisions i think only
strengthen their resolve but i assume
the assassination plot was hatched right
after the missile crisis
i believe that a coup took place in this
country is undeniable
there's indisputable evidence of
crossfire in daly plaza
the us government did all it could to
cover up the assassination not to solve
it i'm talking about
people inside the cia and the fbi that's
what i'm talking about
president kennedy's autopsy was a sham
intended to suppress all evidence of
shots from the front and report only
evidence of shots from the rear
consistent with the official cover story
which is that a man in a building shot a
man in a car
i have to finish in two minutes
so let me just summarize why i say
the autopsy is a sham
i wrote a five volume book documenting
this over 1800 pages so please take my
word for it okay here's here are the
summary points
of why i say the autopsy is a sham
president's body arrived at bethesda 20
minutes prior to the motorcade from
andrews air force base in the wrong
casket and in the wrong vehicle proving
a break in the chain of custody and thus
invalidating the autopsy
that's a medical legal
fact that would have invalidated the
autopsy if it had been known at the time
numerous autopsy photographs and at
least two skull x-rays are missing
the three surviving skullx razor forged
composite copy films they're altered
films
thanks to the work of david mantic we
know this
the conduct of a second fraudulent brain
exam followed the initial brain exam
after the autopsy
things like this just don't happen folks
you're killed by gunshot wound to the
brain there's an autopsy in your body
your brain is preserved the brain is
examined once it's cut up and examined
and photographed there were two brain
exams
following president kennedy's autopsy
the photographs from the second exam
of a substitute brain is what's in the
national archives today
it's not president kennedy's brain
that's imaged in those photographs and
it's not the pattern of damage that was
really in his brain okay that's how you
control
an investigation and that's how you
back a buttress a false autopsy report
the jfk autopsy report in the archives
today is only the third written version
the first two were destroyed one by
burning by dr humes the second one
was kept by robert kennedy never given
to the archives we don't know where it
is today
it's probably at the bottom of the
atlantic ocean in the dallas casket
uh
i'm going to leave you with this closing
thought
right here
the legend constructed around president
kennedy's accused assassin as a castro
sympathizer was clearly a determined
attempt by those who designed the
assassination plot to blame jfk's death
on fidel castro
was jfk's assassination therefore
designed to serve as a northwoods style
pretext
for a u.s invasion of cuba that's my big
question that i leave you with to
consider
the love of pretext was endemic in all
cuba planning throughout 62 and 63.
although president kennedy's
assassination did not trigger an
invasion of cuba it may nevertheless
have been intended to
and in the minds of the operational
planners
the coup plotters who took down
president kennedy it would have been the
perfect revenge
against a president they hated and
despised namely to ensure his death
became the stimulus
for the us military invasion of cuba
that he would never
authorize
thank you
[Applause]
this weekend on american history tv on
c-span three
tonight at eight eastern on lectures in
history
university of washington professor
william rohrbaugh compares the 1950s
beats and beatniks to the hippies of the
1960s
the beats were despairing